LADIES AND GENTLEMEN GOOD
AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
WE HAVE NO ANNOUNCEMENTS AND THE
FIRST ITEM.
IT'S ME AB.
TWO SIXTY THREE AS CHAIR SAID
WE'RE GONNA START FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB.
TWO SIXTY THREE BY CHAIRWOMAN
BURKE AND SHE CAN --
BEGIN WHENEVER SHE'S READY
[inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB TWO
SIXTY THREE WILL EXPAND THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
REVENUE AND TAX CODE SECTION
FORTY ONE TO ALL TAX
EXPENDITURES UNDER THE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX LAW.
AND CORPORATION TAX LAW EXISTING
LAW REQUIRES THAT ALL NEW TAX
CREDITS CONTAINS SPECIFIC GOALS
PURPOSES AND OBJECTIVES ALONG
WITH DETAILED PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO USE.
WHEN EVALUATING THE TAX CREDIT
EFFECTIVENESS WE THINK THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WHICH IS WHY THIS
COMMITTEE HAS MADE A PRACTICE TO
IMPOSE THEM ON ALL NEW TAX
EXPENDITURES NOT JUST TAX
CREDITS?
AND ALTHOUGH ANY NEW BILL CAN
EXEMPT ITSELF FROM THESE
REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL WILL
SERVE AS A BENCHMARK ON THAT
MAKES US BETTER STEWARDS OF OUR
BUDGETARY RESOURCES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I WILL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAMANTHA
CORBIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE --
THE MEASURE INTRODUCED BY MISTER
LENO OR PASSED BY MISTER LENO
EXCUSE ME --
THAT THAT PUT SOME OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ON LAW WE WE HAVE
SEEN AN ENORMOUSLY VALUABLE OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS IT HAS.
GIVEN LEGISLATURE'S THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS ADVOCATES
VERY VALUABLE TOOLS AS THEY MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODIES VALUES AND ABOUT THE
STATE'S VALUES.
IN FACT PART OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING THIS YEAR IS GOING
BACK AND LOOKING AT THE TIME
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
ONE SENATOR LENO.
I HAD INTRODUCED HIS ORIGINAL
MEASURE.
AND THE REASON THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT IS BECAUSE THE HERE'S THE
MEASURES THAT DID NOT HAVE
METRICS THE MEASURES THAT WERE
CHAPTER IN --
THAT DID NOT HAVE SUN SETS THE
BY AND LARGE HAVE GONE ON
TOUCHED FROM ABOUT NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT TO ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE LEAVING.
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF PERHAPS.
A RONI AS TAX CREDITS AN
EXEMPTION ON THE BOX SO WE SEE
THIS IS A NATURAL PROGRESSION OF
THE LAND I LOST SOMETHING VERY
VALUABLE THAT NOT ONLY
COMMITTEES LIKE YOURS --
BUT THE ENTIRE BODY CAN USE AND
SETTING THE VALUES OF THE STATE
THROUGH THE BUDGET AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE IN SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I CAN -- UP
JUST REAL QUICKLY WE HAVE A FEW
OTHER MEMBERS HERE AND WE WANT
TO ESTABLISH COR.
NOT A CLERK [inaudible]
BURKE HERE [inaudible]
ROBERT [inaudible]
TO GREAT [inaudible]
MAYES.
LENDERS WILL [inaudible]
ONE PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE.
REVERSE [inaudible]
TING.
CORD BELLCORE MY APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T YET HAVE AN
OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION WE
WILL HAVE ONE CODIFIED --
AT OUR MEMBERS MEETING NEXT
WEEKEND --
BUT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY --
CONSISTENT WITH THE VALUES AND
VISIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN --
WORKING TOWARDS WE VERY MUCH
SITE THAT THIS MEASURE WILL
PROVIDE WE DO BELIEVE THAT PAUL
TAX CREDITS AND TAX EXEMPTIONS
HAVE BEEN CREATED TO PROVIDE AN
ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIA.
IS WELL IS TO CREATE INCENTIVES
TO CREATE PARTICULAR GOALS AND
OUTCOMES IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOCUS ON
THESE AREAS ARE BEING WELL SPENT
TO JUSTIFY THE REDUCTIONS IN
CRITICAL EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
POLICY PROGRAMS.
HAS 40% OF EVERY DOLLAR A TAX
CREDIT IS CREEK THAT IS CREATED
ACTUALLY WOULD HAVE GONE TO FIND
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS SO
WE APPRECIATE THE LONG TERM
ECONOMIC OVERSIGHT THIS MEASURE
WILL ACHIEVE.
MOVE THE BILL.
WELL MOTION BY MISTER GRAY A
SECOND MEMBERS QUIRK WILL ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
XENON BRAVE ACTUALLY DíAS VENOM
LIKE.
TO MISTER BANKS YEAH I JUST WANT
THEM TO SUPPORT THIS --
TODAY -- BUT
PROBABLY NOT FOR SOME OF THE
REASONS THAT MANY OF YOU MIGHT
THINK YEAH --
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD CALL
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES --
LIKE IS WHAT HAS BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT THE PURPOSE OF OUR OF OF
OF TAXING.
OF CITIZENS IS TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY OF SERVICES --
TO THE TO THE PUBLIC AND EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE ONE CREDIT OR
ANOTHER YOU ARE IN ESSENCE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS --
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE SOME
MECHANISM BUT PLACE IT SAYS
THERE'S SOME REALLY REALLY
REALLY GOOD REASON. FOR THAT
THEN I'M NOT SURE THAT WE SHOULD
IN THE COUNTRY I THINK THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE HE AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE ALL THESE OTHER.
CREDITS AND SO FORTH SO I THINK
THIS MAKES A AN AWFUL LOT OF
SENSE A PROBABLY FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS --
BUT I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
THEY GIVE US MAYES WAS COURT --
I TAKE THE POSITION THERE SHOULD
BE NO TAX DEDUCTIONS.
TAX DEDUCTIONS.
FAVOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
FAVOR THE RICH.
IF YOU HAVE A MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR HOME AND YOU'RE BEING
TAXED AT 13%.
YOU GET A LOT MORE MONEY BACK
THAN SOMEBODY WHO A BARELY PAYS
TAXES ALL THIS PAIN IT 23%.
SO IN MY OPINION THE ULTIMATE
REFORM WOULD BE TO GET RID OF
ALL TAX DEDUCTIONS.
NOW I'M SURE CHAD YOU'D WANT
THAT TO BE REVENUE NEUTRAL WE
COULD TALK ABOUT THAT.
EXCUSE ME THE MAYOR FROM PALM
DESERT.
NOW WELL WHATEVER.
SHE'S [inaudible]
AMBER WEDDING.
CLOSE ENOUGH --
BUT TAX DEDUCTIONS ARE BREAKS
FOR THE RICH WE OUGHT TO GET RID
OF THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIGITAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK.
I'M JUST SAD I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE THE CHAIR YOU
KNOW THIS IS MY FIFTH YEAR.
AND THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW TAX REFORM HAS BEEN
GOING ON BUT OTHER THAN MISTER
HERTZBERG ATTEMPT TO START A
DISCUSSION NOTHING'S REALLY
HAPPENED.
AND MISS CORBIN I'VE HAD THESE
COVER NOTHING REALLY HAPPENED --
YEAH I'LL TAKE THIS IS PERFECT
BUT I THINK IT'S A START TO GET
THE CONVERSATION GOING SO --
JUST ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THAT [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISH TO
SPEAK WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
GRAY SECOND MY MISSED QUIRK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE I WORK ON A BRAILLE.
BROWN NOT VOTING. TO GRAY.
GRAY AYE MAYES.
ARM LENDERS MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HI BURKE AYE REAVIS REAVIS
AYE TING.
SO THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
WHO'S HERE NEXT.
I'M SORRY.
WITH THAT --
THE NEXT ITEM UP IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB FIVE THIRTY THREE
BY MISTER
.
MR HOLDEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE --
TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY THREE TODAY.
WATER CONSERVATION AND STORM
WATER PROGRAM REBATES AND
INCENTIVES ARE DESIGNED TO
REIMBURSE HOUSEHOLDS WERE
EXPENSES INCURRED TO UPGRADE
APPLIANCES.
INSTALL CISTERNS OR REMOVE AND
REPLACE THEIR LAWNS WITH DROUGHT
TOLERANT PLANTS.
HOWEVER THESE REBATE FUNDS THAT
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING CONNECTION
WITH THESE PROGRAMS ARE
POTENTIALLY TAXABLE UNDER STATE
LAW.
AB FIVE THIRTY THREE PROVIDES
CLARITY UNCERTAINTY FOR WATER
AGENCIES THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO CUSTOMERS.
CONSUMERS WITHOUT THE BURDEN OF
ISSUING TEN NINETY NINES OR
CONCERNS THAT THEIR CONSUMERS
WILL BE DISCOURAGED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THESE.
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS BY AN
ADDITIONAL TAX BURDEN.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT
POLICIES THAT INCENTIVIZE WATER
CONSERVATION AND EXTENDING TAX
RELIEF ON ALREADY PROVEN
PROGRAMS AS A WIN FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND CONSUMERS.
I WOULD DEFER THE REST OF MY
TIME -- TO
MY SPONSORS WHO ARE HERE TO
SHARE WHY THIS BILL IS CRITICAL.
TO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE WITH ME --
KATHY BY TELE.
BE A TELE.
OFFER METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SIMPLY CYNTHIA KOHLER.
FROM WATER NOW ALLIANCE AND SIR
FOLEY FROM CALIFORNIA WATER
EFFICIENCY PARTNERSHIP.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S CATHY VIA TELEPHONE AND
I'M WITH THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
A COALITION LETTER OF THIRTY SIX
SIGNATORIES REPRESENTING WATER
AGENCIES BUSINESSES TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS AND NON PROFITS
COMMITTED TO TO WATER
CONSERVATION AS A CALIFORNIA WAY
OF LIFE.
WAS SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE
THREE THREE MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN WE WISH TO THANK.
MR HOLDEN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
FOR A THREE WHICH WOULD EXCLUDE
FROM GROSS INCOME ANY AMOUNT
RECEIVED AS A REBATE VOUCHER OR
OTHER FINANCIAL INCENTIVE.
ISSUED BY A LOCAL WATER AGENCY
OR WATER SUPPLIER FOR EXPENSES
INCURRED TO PARTICIPATE IN UTTER
FOR MOBILE WATER CONSERVATION
PROGRAM FOR STORM WATER RUNOFF.
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY METROPOLITAN HAS
INVESTED MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND MAIL EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN REBATES AND OTHER
CONSERVATION INCENTIVES.
THE RESULTING IN AN ESTIMATED
WATER SAVINGS OF TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION ACRE FEET ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE WATER FOR NEARLY NINE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS.
METROPOLITAN SO CAL WATER SMART
PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
TWENTY SIX MEMBER AGENCIES.
PROVIDES RESIDENTIAL AND
CORPORATE REBATES THE TYPES OF
RESIDENTIAL REBATES INCLUDE HIGH
EFFICIENCY TOILETS CLOTHES
WASHERS AND HIGH EFFICIENCY
SPRINKLER NOZZLE SOIL MOISTURE
SENSORS AND WATER BASED
IRRIGATION CONTROLLERS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE REBATES FOR RAIN
BARRELS AND CISTERNS.
AND JANUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE DROUGHT
METROPOLITAN EDITOR FOR MOBILE
TO OUR PROGRAM.
IT WAS OUR MOST POPULAR WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM AND IN APRIL
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE EXTENDED
THAT PROGRAMMING CALLED AT THE
LANDSCAPE TRANSFORM TRANSFORM
PROGRAM.
METROPOLITAN HAS A GOAL TO SAVE
A HUNDED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET OF WATER PER YEAR BY
TWENTY FORTY AND WE ARE MAKING
STEADY PROGRESS TOWARD THIS GOAL
THROUGH THE SO CAL WATER SMART
PROGRAM.
BUT WE ACHIEVE MORE CONSERVATION
BY FOCUSING ON OUTDOOR WATER USE
OUR BOARD AUTHORIZED FIFTY
MILLION FOR TOURNEFORT REBATE
PROGRAM IN FEBRUARY THEY
INCREASE THE TURF REBATE FROM A
DOLLAR PER ACRE TO TWO DOLLARS
PER ACRE FOOT.
I'M SORRY PER ACRE ALONG WITH
SOME OTHER CHANGES TO
INCENTIVIZE GREATER.
PARTICIPATION.
TURF REPLACEMENT REBATES HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM A TAX EXEMPT
EXEMPTION THANKS TO AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY FOUR FROM FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOMEZ ENACTED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN HOWEVER THAT
EXEMPTION SUNSET AT THE
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE FOR
WATER SAVING TOILETS AND CLOTHES
WASHERS.
MAKING THE TAX EXCLUSION FOR
TURF REMOVAL PERMANENT OR
EXTENDING ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
WILL PROVIDE RELIEF TO STATE
TAXPAYERS AND COULD ENCOURAGE
GREATER PARTICIPATION ENTER FOR
MOBILE PROGRAMS.
WHILE THE SOUTH PLAN WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY FACE VERY ABLE
ECONOMIC AND HYDROLOGIC
CONDITIONS IN THE FUTURE THE
REGION HAS ESTABLISHED A SOLID
FOUNDATION --
FOR ACHIEVEMENTS IN CONSERVATION
AND EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY THREE CAN
PROVIDE CONTINUED RELIEF TO
STATE TAXPAYERS TO FURTHER
FACILITATE STATEWIDE GOALS. TO
LOWER WATER USE FOR THESE
REASONS METROPOLITAN AND ARE
SIGNATORIES TO OUR COALITION
LETTER SUPPORT AB FIVE THREE
THREE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE. TO LOOK FAVORABLY
UPON THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M SERRA FULLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF TWO HUNDRED
WATER UTILITIES.
NGOS AND CONSERVATION
PROFESSIONALS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION THE FORMER
STATE INCOME TAX EXEMPTION FOR
TURF REPLACEMENT AS YOU JUST
HEARD REBATES.
EXPIRED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS
BILL GIVES A NEW STATE INCOME
TAX EXEMPTION FOR WATER
EFFICIENCY REBATES IN GENERAL
AND FOR GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE NEEDED TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S WATER
RESOURCES AND CONSUMER SHOULD
NOT BE PERSONALLY TAXED FOR
PROVIDING A STATEWIDE BENEFIT.
WE'RE WORKING ON GETTING A
FEDERAL TAX EXEMPTION AS WELL.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY REBATES HAVE
BEEN EXEMPT FROM FEDERAL AND
STATE INCOME TAX FOR DECADES.
DOING THIS FOR WATER EFFICIENCY
PROVIDES PARITY WITH WHAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN ENERGY.
ONCE THIS BILL IS PASSED AT BOTH
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS TEN
NINETY NINES WILL NO LONGER NEED
TO BE SENT BY WATER UTILITIES.
TO CUSTOMERS WHO GET SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR MORE REBATES IN A
CALENDAR YEAR.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND URGE THE THANK YOU.
IF YOU HAD TO TESTIFY SO IF YOU
COULD BE BRIEF I WILL BE.
VERY BRIEF.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
CYNTHIA COLOR WITH THE WATER NOW
ALLIANCE --
WE ARE A NATIONAL NETWORK OF
WATER UTILITY LEADERSHIP --
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE AND
RESILIENT WATER SOLUTIONS AND
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF MR
HOLDINGS BILL AB FIVE THIRTY
THREE WHAT I'LL ADD TO MY
COLLEAGUES TESTIMONY IS THAT --
WE SEE THAT CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION IN DECENTRALIZED
WATER --
TECHNOLOGIES AND STRATEGIES IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE STATE ACHIEVING
THEIR GOALS OF WATER RESILIENCE
AND BY THAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING
NOT ONLY ABOUT TURF BUT ABOUT
GRAY WATER SYSTEMS LEAK
DETECTION DEVICES.
THAT ARE ALL FAIRLY EXPENSIVE WE
KNOW THAT UTILITY PARTICIPATION
UTILITIES ABILITY TO HAVE
CONSUMER REBATES IS ESSENTIAL TO
ACHIEVING THESE GOALS WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
TAX BOARDS ANALYSIS --
AND FEEL THAT IT MAY HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER STATED THE
LIKELY LOSS.
IN REVENUE TO THE STATE AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROHIBITION I'M
REALLY PROGRAMS OF COURSE ARE
VOLUNTARY WE CANNOT FORCE
PARTICIPATION AND WE KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE THAT --
PEOPLE THAT PERCEIVE A TAX --
A PENALTY WILL NOT HURT SINCE OF
THIS PROGRAM IS A CAP WILL BE
WE'VE BASICALLY SAYING UTILITIES
ARE CAPPED TO SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR THEIR PROGRAMS TO
WHICH SHE WATER EFFICIENCY WHICH
IS SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN WE
WILL.
THEN WE WILL NEED TO ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS -- IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'LL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT --
WE BELIEVE THAT AB FIVE THIRTY
THREE IS THE LOGICAL EXTENSION
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S LONG
STANDING RECOGNITION ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR UTILITIES TO
BE ABLE TO USE CONSUMER REBATES
TO ADVANCE NOT ONLY THEIR OWN
BUT STATE WIDE.
RESILIENCE AND WATER EFFICIENCY
GOALS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AND I
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND I'M
HAVE TO LEAD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN AFFILIATION ONLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
THINK MANAGER MEMBERS WERE TOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE ALSO WE HAVE THE
CITY OF PASADENA AND SUPPORT.
HELLO CHRISTY FOR A WITH THREE
VALUES MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
STEVE KERR'S ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
EMILY PAPPAS FOR EASTER
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
IF ANY MILLION ON BEHALF OF SAN
GABRIEL --
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT AND IS
A MESA WATER DISTRICT AS WELL.
RYAN AND JACKING WITH THE
REGIONAL WATERS AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
NO WELL MEDIC WITH THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE IN SUPPORT.
EMILY REAP ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS WAIT I KNOW
ISSUES COME IN.
SAMANTHA GORMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
SEE TERRY DOES NOT OPPOSE
EXCLUDING A SMALL REPAID A
REBATE EXCUSE ME ON A WATER BILL
FROM -- FROM
INCOME FOR HOUSEHOLDS HOWEVER WE
DO FEEL THAT IS WRITTEN THIS
BILL GOES TOO FAR INCLUDING
EXEMPTIONS FOR LARGE USERS AND
CORPORATIONS FURTHERMORE WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE USE OF THE
TERM FINANCIAL INCENTIVE WHICH
WE BELIEVE IS SO VEGAS TO
SUGGEST.
ANY NUMBER OF POTENTIAL
SUBSIDIES --
AND AS THE ANALYSIS RIGHTLY
NOTES THE PREVIOUS GROSS INCOME
EXCLUSIONS SPECIFICALLY APPLIED
TO REBATES ISSUED FOR
PARTICIPATION TURF REMOVAL
PROGRAMS WHICH WAS MENTIONED.
BUT THIS MEASURE GOES FAR FAR
BROADER WATER CONSERVATION
PROGRAM OR ANY PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO EITHER REDUCE OR MANAGE STORM
WATER RUNOFF --
THIS IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION ON WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY --
IN ADDITION WERE ENGAGED IN A
MUCH LARGER CONVERSATION THIS
YEAR REGARDING FEDERAL TAX
CONFORMITY IN THE STATE BUDGET
THIS MEASURE WOULD BE OUT OF
ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL TAX
CONFORMITY EFFORTS ON FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THE MEASURE IS
SPREADING.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK --
SO I I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE HOWEVER.
LIKE ALL TAX DEDUCTIONS AND IN
FACT THIS IS A DEDUCTION YOU'RE
GETTING TO DEDUCT.
FROM YOUR DO TAXES WHAT YOU WERE
PAID BY THE DISTRICT.
IN AFFECTED TO DEDUCTION WHICH
AT ANY RATE SOMEBODY EARNING A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IS GOING
TO GET 13% BENEFIT.
SOMEBODY EARNING THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND GETS 4% TALK ABOUT
MARRIED COUPLES.
I JUST WHAT I WOULD RATHER SEE
YOU DO IF YOU WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THIS SORT OF WORK.
IS IT WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE
FRANKLY FOR THE STATE. TO
SUBSIDIZE THE DISTRICTS OF THAT
THEY COULD GIVE SOMEWHAT HIGHER --
REBATES BUT THEN YOU'D BE GIVING
THE SAME REBATE. TO A PERSON WHO
MADE YOU MADE A MILLION.
THAT THAT'S MY CONCERN HERE
YOU'RE YOU'RE BASICALLY GIVING
THEM A BETTER BREAK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO EARN MORE.
I WENT OVER AND TURNED TO MISS
FUTILITY TO RESPOND I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE BUT I
THINK THAT --
WILL HAVE A MORE DETAILED
RESPONSE IN MISTER --
MISTER PARK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE AS
WELL THESE ARE ACTUALLY
EXEMPTIONS THESE ARE NOT CREDITS.
SO THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS IS
THAT A HOUSEHOLD WOULD ENROLL IN
OUR TURF REPLACE.
REBATE --
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AND THEN
UPON SUBMITTING INFORMATION TO
US THAN THEY WOULD RECEIVE A
REBATE SO THEY ARE REIMBURSED
ACTUALLY SO IT'S ESSENTIALLY
IT'S LIKE A GRANT --
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING TO THEM
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEN THEY GET A
TEN NINETY NINE A FEDERAL TEN
NINETY NINE AND THEN THEY
REALIZE THAT THAT AMOUNT THAT
WE'VE GRANTED TO THEM AS THE
REBATE.
IS THEN SUBJECT TO INCOME TAX
AND THAT'S WHERE THE ISSUE COMES
UP SO WE'RE NOT TREATING THEM AS
CREDITS.
ON THIS IS ACTUALLY THIS IS --
SO IT'S NOT INCOME PER SE WELL
AT ANY RATE YOU ARE GIVING THE
BIGGEST BREAK TO THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE THE MOST MONEY.
THAT'S MY CONCERN.
YOU'RE GIVING THEM 13% BACK THEY
WOULD ORDINARILY PAY 13% ON SAY
A HUNDRED DOLLARS THEY'D BE
PAYING THIRTEEN DOLLARS IN TAX.
WHERE SOMEBODY WHO MADE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND WOULD BE PAYING TWO
DOLLARS IN TAX SO YOU'RE GIVING
THE BIGGEST BREAK TO THE PERSON
WHO MAKES THE MOST MONEY?
THAT'S MY CONCERN AND I WOULD
RATHER SEE A PROGRAM THAT GIVES
THE SAME BREAK TO EVERYBODY AND
THERE ARE WAYS TO DESIGN THAT.
BUT NOT THIS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING MAKE MORE MONEY.
THIS IS A CONCERN I HAVE WITH
ALL THE BILLS THAT COME THROUGH
HERE. TO BE FAIR HE'S BEING
HONEST THIS IS A CONCERN HAS
WITH ALL THOSE.
I DON'T THINK YES.
AND AND BECAUSE HE'S HAD A
CONCERN IT'S A VALID CONCERN
THAT WE'VE SEEN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN IN THIS COMMITTEE WHICH IS
WHY WE WERE JUST DOING THE LAST
BILL THAT WE WE WENT THROUGH --
BECAUSE IT IS A GENUINE CONCERN
OF THIS COMMITTEE IS THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THESE OPPORTUNITIES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT LOWER
INCOME FOLKS ARE ARE ACTUALLY
WITH THE ONES GETTING THE
BENEFIT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
MILLIONAIRES TAKING GREAT
ADVANTAGE OF OF SOME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE.
THAT THAT THOSE FUNDS HER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES COMMENTS
WHEN AND BEST BE SPENT --
WITH A LOWER INCOME INDIVIDUAL
OR IN A SOCIAL SERVICES KIND OF
ASPECT.
BUT THAT BEING SAID ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER ALL THE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
WELL THANK YOU AND I I DO
APPRECIATE A DOCTOR QUIRKS A
CONCERN -- I
THINK THAT IT'S THE EXPECTATION
QUITE FRANKLY OF ANY BILL
PRESENTED IN A COMMITTEE THAT IF.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS
VIEW --
AMENDMENT THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED WERE CERTAINLY OPEN
TO HEAR AND WHAT THAT MIGHT
REPRESENT --
TO WEAR COULD APPLY SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE I DON'T THINK WE GOT A
HEADS UP THAT THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT WE COULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REVIEW SOMEONE MAY
WE HAVE ALLOWED US.
TO MAYBE.
THE IN ALIGNMENT WITH WITH YOUR
THINKING ON THIS BUT I THINK WE
HAVE NOTES FROM YOUR OFFICE
SAYING THAT YES IN FACT SO YOU
HAVE EXPRESSED WILLINGNESS TO TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH THAT
SO YES. TO DO THAT.
SO -- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE COMMITTEE
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
WITH OUR OFFICE AND HOPEFULLY
HAVE A FAVORABLE REVIEW OF OF
THE MATTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWELVE A. B.
C. -- AWAY
WE'RE GONNA DO ADD ONS. TO FILE
ITEM ONE AB TWO SIXTY THREE CALL
THE ABSENTEES. TO HIGHER SHOES I
MULLIN THIS.
MELINDA IS NOT LOADING
[inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS BETWEEN
NORTH SIDE THAT'S IT FOR THAT.
THANK YOU --
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
SIX FOURTEEN DOCTOR EGGMAN SO IF
THERE'S SB.
SIX FOURTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I
HOPE I HAVE A BILL THAT MR QUIRK
IS GONNA LIKE.
I DO LIKE IT ALL RIGHT THE CITY
THERE WERE.
ALREADY GONE ALL RIGHT BECAUSE
THIS BILL.
RATHER THAN TO GIVING TAX BREAKS
TO THE WEALTHY.
IS GIVING FOOD TO THE POOR.
SB SIX FOURTEEN WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO FRESH FRUITS TO TO
FRESH AND HEALTHY FOODS --
FOR IN SECURE FAMILIES BY
EXPANDING THE FARM TO FOOD BANK
TAX CREDIT.
CURRENTLY YOU CAN ONLY DONATE
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
THAT'S ALL LEAVES A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS THAT.
PERHAPS GOING TO LANDFILL OR
JUST GETTING THROUGH --
THAT CAN GO TO FOOD BANKS THINGS
LIKE NOT STEP.
SALSA AB ME AEGS DAIRY THERE'S
ABOUT WEALTH OF THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY NOT INCLUDED IN WHAT
CAN BE DONATED. TO THIS BILL
WILL EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF TYPES
OF FOOD THAT CAN BE DONATED IT'S
A WIN WIN IT PROVIDES ANOTHER
MARKET FOR FARMERS WHO OFF
OFTENTIMES HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT.
THEY ARE ABLE TO USE IT PROVIDES
MORE FRESH HEALTHY FOOD FOR OUR
LOW INCOME.
FAMILIES WHO NEED TOMORROW
ACCESS TO FRESH AND HEALTHY FOOD --
AND WE THINK IT'S A GOOD POLICY
IN GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA AND ONE
OF THE MOST BIPARTISAN BILLS IN
THE HOUSE.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ANDREW
CHASE --
FROM CALIFORNIA AGAINST WASTE
CHAIN I GUESS FOR A CAB FROM
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND BONNIE BEEN A WALL
FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THE COMMITMENT THE SHEIK
INTERCHANGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS I'LL
JUST BE VERY BRIEF THAT WE DO
HAVE EXTREMELY HIGH RATES OF
HUNGER -- TO
THEM AND CHILDREN THIS IN THE
STATE -- AND
OF COURSE HALLWAYS SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC NUTRITION PROGRAMS LIKE
CAL FRESH --
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT THREATS
AGAINST THESE AND EVEN FOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE ON CAL FRESH
ONE THIRD STILL COME TO FOOD
BANKS BECAUSE THE BENEFITS JUST
DON'T LAST A MONTH.
INTO THE REALLY IS A NEED FOR
THE SIX IT BEHIND THE SAFETY NET --
AND AS A MEMBER EGGMAN POINTED
OUT WE HAVE AN EFFECTIVE --
POLICIES TO INCENTIVIZE
DONATIONS OF FRESH FRUIT
VEGETABLES BUT WE SIMPLY NEED TO
FILL THE REST OF THE GROCERY BAG.
THANK YOU.
AND MADAME TRIED TO BRING --
DISCREETLY THE LOS ANGELES --
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS
EXACTLY THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
CANNED PROTEINS THE PEANUT
BUTTER AND JELLY THE CAMPUS AND
VEGETABLES AND THE STAPLES BEANS
RICE AND PASTA THIS IS LITTLE
WITH THE BANKS?
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BY
MAIL FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU TODAY
INVOICE OR STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY SIX FOURTEEN I LIKE
TO THINK IT'S TIME WE MEMBER
SUSAN EGGMAN FOR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC.
CALIFORNIA DATA SHOWS THAT FOOD
WASTE IS MOST PREVALENT ITEM IN
OUR LANDFILLS WITH OVER FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION TONS OF FOOD
DUMPED EVERY YEAR.
THIS GENERATES A POINT THREE
MILLION TONNES OF GREENHOUSE
GASES EACH YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
ENERGY RESPONSIBLE 420% OF THE
STATE'S METHANE EMISSIONS --
AT THE SAME TIME IS ANDREW
DISCUSSED --
THERE ARE --
A LARGE PORTION OF OUR
POPULATION THAT REMAIN FOOD INTO
CARE.
I WAS --
SEEN BY THE EXISTING TAX CREDIT
GIVE INCENTIVIZING FOOD
DONATIONS MOST EFFICIENT AND
PRACTICAL WAY TO REDUCE THE
VOLUME OF FOOD WASTE AT THE
SOURCE AND FEED HUNGRY FAMILIES.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A COME SINCE
TAX CREDIT MUST BE EXPANDED TO
OTHER TYPES OF STAPLE FOODS
NEEDED THAT OUR FOOD BANKS.
AB SIX FORTY WOULD PROVIDE
FARMERS WITH THE COST SAVINGS
THAT CAN BE REINVESTED INTO
THEIR ASSETS AND COMMUNITIES.
AND BENEFIT THE ENVIRONMENT BY
CUTTING THE AMOUNT OF ROTTING
FOOD CONTRIBUTING TO METHANE
EMISSIONS AND CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU
ADDITIONAL IS IS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS TAYLOR
RUSH WITH CALIFORNIA FARM HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW ON WITH WESTERN GROWERS
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEAMAN COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A SIMILAR LONDON.
I'M THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM.
MISSING WHEN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
THIS IS A BILL THAT I I I THINK.
I THINK YOU JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY
ON THIS.
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY VOTED FOR
IN FAVOR OF SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
AS TO HAVE YOU HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE NEW
GOVERNOR --
ABOUT DO YOU KNOW.
POSSIBLY NOT VETOING THIS BILL
LIKE THE LAST GOVERNOR DID.
WHEN THE WHEN THE APPROPRIATE
TIME IS?
WE WILL AND WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE NEW
GOVERNOR ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN DIFFERENT WAYS THAT THAT CAN
BE SUPPORTED YEAH BECAUSE IT'S I
MEAN IT DOES SEEM KIND OF SILLY
TO NOT ALLOW THESE TYPES OF
FOODS TO BE DONATED TO WHEN THEY
COULD BE COULD FRANKLY.
I THINK IT IS A WIN WIN LIKE YOU
SAID WHICH IS WHY WE'VE ALL
SUPPORT IT BUT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PERSISTENCE AND HOPEFULLY
THIS TIME YOU GET IT THROUGH
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THIRTY ONE JUDGE CLOSE.
JUST A WOULD ASK FOR YOUR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS TO COME
OFF THANK YOU.
MOVING A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWO FIFTY IS DOCTOR CHOI HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SODOMY FIRST OF PRESENT
DAY AB.
THREE FIFTY AND I HAVE --
OR SO A A. B. --
TWO FIFTY TODAY I AM PRESENTING
AB -- THREE
FIFTY TO MAKE A COLLEGE --
FIVE TWENTY NINE CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE TAX DEDUCTIBLE.
COLLEGES. FIVE TWO FIVE TO NINE
PLANS AREN'T MARKET INVESTMENT
ACCOUNTS. FOR THE PURPOSE OFF OF
FINANCING FUTURE EDUCATION
RELATED EXPENSES --
SUCH AS A TUITION BOOKS HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND TECHNOLOGY.
ON'T DELUDE CALIFORNIA'S SELF
PUBLIC. FIVE TWENTY NINE FUND
DAYS SO RATED THE NUMBER.
TEN IN THE NATION FOR IS OF
COURSE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
WHY THIS IS AMAZING AND THAT
DEFINITELY --
ARM PROMOTE SO INVESTMENT OF FOR
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA IS OUT ONE
OF THE ONLY SIX STATES.
THAT HAVE A INCOME TAX AND THE
DO NOT.
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF A TAX
DEDUCTION OR TAX CREDIT FOR
INVESTMENT SO IN FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN SOME.
BY PROVIDING KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
SUCH INVESTMENTS AND THE OPENING
UP OF BENEFITS OF FOR ALL
RESIDENTS PRESTON SO.
A TO ENJOY A FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANS CAN HELP OFFSET THE
GROWING RISE OF A STRING THAT.
AND THE MAKE FUTURE EDUCATION
MORE AFFORDABLE BY OR SHOULD ON
SO ACROSS THE STATE.
I HAVE ALREADY --
SUBMITTED ON LANGUAGE IT --
TO LEDGE COUNSELOR A TO AMANDA
AB THREE FIFTY TO BRING IT INTO
THE GUIDELINES SO THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS SO REQUESTED.
I'M MAKING IT UP TO HALF A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET.
ON THE TEXT DEDUCTION AND A
SECTION FORTY ONE COMPLIANCE TO
MATCH A MONTH AND THE GOAL.
WITH ME TODAY TO GIVE A
TESTIMONY AS MISTER SCOTT THE
KAUFMAN THE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION.
AND THE WORKFORCE THE WITH THE
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE --
EXCHANGE COUNCIL.
THANK YOU INNOCENT SUPPORT HI.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'LL MAKE THIS BRIEF CAUSE THIS
IN THE MINORITY --
MADE MOST OF THE IMPORTANT
POINTS BUT ALSO IN A COLLEGE IS
COMING INCREASINGLY ON
AFFORDABLE. FOR MANY STUDENT
LOAN DEBT THIS OUR PAST CREDIT
CARD DEBT IS NOW SECOND ONLY TO
MORTGAGE DEBT.
AMERICANS --
MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION IN STUDENT LOANS AND
COLLEGE TUITIONS INCREASE AT
TWICE THE RATE OF INFLATION. ONE
TWO ON THE TOOL BELT IS
INCENTIVIZING SAVING AND
INVESTING IN CALL IN COLLEGE BY
PRE FUNDING PLANS.
THAT CAN HELP ALLEVIATE THE NEED
TO TAKE OUT LOANS OR AT LEAST
MITIGATE THE NEED TO TAKE OUT SO
MANY. THIRTY FIVE STATES AND
JUST GO COLUMBIA OFFER A INCOME
TAX BENEFIT OR CREDIT AND SEVEN
STATES.
OFFER INCOME TAX BENEFITS FOR
ANY AND ALL FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANS. EIGHT STATES HAVE NO
PERSONAL INCOME TAX SO.
EITHER TO GEORGIA FACT OTHERS
FORTY TWO STATES THAT HAVE A
BENEFIT IN THIS ARENA.
IN CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF
ONLY SIX IT DOES NOT --
AFFORD ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS I
HAVE A FEELING I'LL I'LL GET ONE
ABOUT TAX DEDUCTIONS
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
JOANNE BUT IN COURT.
REPRESENTING THE SECURITIES
INDUSTRY AND FINANCIAL MARKETS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AB AT THREE FIFTY LIKE.
MY COLLEAGUE HERE SAID THAT SOME
WOMEN OF MEMBER CHOI --
DID A GOOD JOB EXPLAINING THE
PROGRAM IS SO I'M JUST GOING --
TO TO TALK ABOUT A COUPLE OF OF
POINTS.
SO SET UP THAT SUPPORTS THE BILL
WHICH WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
TO DEDUCT CONTRIBUTIONS TO ANY.
QUALIFIED FOR IT FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN FROM THEIR GROSS
INCOME TAX INCOME FOR STATE
INCOME TAX PURPOSES.
SEE THAT TWICE FOR FAST.
UP.
WE'LL THE LEGISLATURE WILL TAKE
IN ACCOUNT A COUPLE OF POINTS
WHEN THEY'RE CONSIDERING THIS
BILL AND OTHER FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLAN BILLS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FACTORS THAT
GO INTO CONSIDERING WHAT FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN TO CHOOSE.
THEY ARE.
INVESTOR INVESTOR RISK TOLERANCE
[inaudible]
FEES CHARGED.
THE PLANS PAST PERFORMANCE.
THE ABILITY THE AVAILABILITY TO
THE AVAILABILITY TO WORK WITH A
TRUSTED ADVISER.
AMONG OTHER CONSIDERATIONS.
THE TAX DEDUCTION FOR JUST ONE
SPOT STATES FOR JUST THE STATE
SPONSORED PLAN EFFECTIVELY LIMIT
INVESTOR CHOICE BY MAKING THE
DRIVING FACTOR.
WHERE THE DEDUCTION IS AVAILABLE
RATHER THE WHICH FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN BEST SUITS?
THE COLLEGE SAVERS OVERALL
POSITION.
OR NEEDS --
LASTLY HE TOUCH ON A LITTLE BIT
BUT ALL FIVE TWENTY LIKE ANY
QUALIFIED BY TWENTY NINE PLANS.
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN SEVEN
OTHER STATES SO AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE URGE YOUR
IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IS IN OPPOSITION?
I JUST SO YOU CAN SIT DOWN.
MADAM CHAIRMEMBERS ASKED ME IN
THE CURRENT WITH CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE --
SIMILAR TO OUR OPPOSITION TO AB --
TWO ONE ONE BY MISTER CALDERON I
WE DO HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL --
SPECIFICALLY AND AND THIS IS
REFLECTED THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
FOR THAT THERE IS WAS A SURVEY
RECENTLY DONE OR A COUPLE YEARS
BACK BASICALLY SAYING THAT IS
OVERWHELMING 68% OF PEOPLE
SURVEYED COULD NOT USE FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLANS.
DID NOT USE THEM BECAUSE THEY
LACKED THE MONEY IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- AND
SO IN KEEPING WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MR QUIRK IS MADE --
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY TO
SAVE WHO ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY
TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD COLLEGE
WILL BE ABLE.
TO GET A TAX BREAK FROM DOING
SOMETHING THEY WOULD IN FACT
ALREADY DO WHERE AS THOSE WHO
ARE LEAST LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
SAVE OR TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
COLLEGE --
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS
INCENTIVE --
MOREOVER THE COST OF SUCH AN
INCENTIVE.
WILL REDUCE FUNDING TO STATE
PROGRAMS BOTH BY PROP --
NINETY EIGHT FOR K. FOR FOURTEEN
BUT FOR OTHER STATE FUNDS FOR US
YES YOU AND UC'S AS WELL AND
SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL THERE WAS
A TIME WHEN STATE COLLEGES WERE
ACTUALLY FREE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
AND AS THOSE TUITIONS HAVE
CONTINUED TO INCREASE --
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AND WHAT
ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO DO IS
ACTUALLY TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE OLDER TAX CREDITS
EXEMPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR YEARS AND ARE DRAINING
THE STATE BY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS?
AS A MEANS TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR PARK --
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY --
BUT LET ME SKIP THAT PART WE
HAVE A BILL.
WE HAVE A BILL THAT'S BEEN
SUBMITTED A. B. FIFTEEN BY IN
THIS AREA MCCARTY AND TANG.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS GIVES ANYONE
WHO WILL SET UP AN ACCOUNT OF
THIS TYPE FOR KIDS WHO ARE BORN
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
DETAILS AND GIVE EVERYONE --
THE SAME AMOUNT --
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR VARIOUS WAYS
TO FUND THESE ACCOUNTS.
THE OTHER THING WE COULD DO IS
JUST READ THE EIGHT REDUCE
TUITION.
AT CSU AND AND USE BETTER
APPROACHES THEM --
REWARDING PEOPLE WITH THE MOST
MONEY GETTING THE BIGGEST BREAK
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS --
MISTER BROWN THEY SOUND CHAIR DR
CHOI THANKS FOR BRINGING US FOR
WE TRIED THIS A COUPLE YEARS AGO
IT.
WAS HELD IN COMMITTEE --
MISTER CALDERON SCOTT IT SO
HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS CAN GET
TOGETHER AND HAVE THIS BE A BI
PARTISAN VEHICLE --
I'D LOOK AT MYSELF FOR MY KIDS
BUT THERE'S NO REAL INCENTIVE --
TO DO IT AND AS WE LEARN FROM
THE TREASURE LAST WEEK --
SHE SAID CALIFORNIANS ARE GOING
TO OTHER STATES THAT OFFER
INCENTIVES AND PUT THEIR MONEY
IN FIVE TWENTY NINES OTHER
STATES.
SO -- WE CAN
KEEP THAT MONEY HERE I DO AGREE
MISTER QUIRK WE GOT A LOWER THE
TUITION THAT'S A BIG PART OF IT.
AND UP WE ALSO LEARNED LAST WEEK
THERE'S OTHER WAYS YOU CAN GET
STUDENTS IN COLLEGE.
TO WHERE ALTERNATE STANDARD JAIL
YEAR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN AND ORDER TO I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YES THIS IS SIDE EXACTLY THE RE
SON -- THAT --
I WOULD LIKE TO INCENTIVIZE THE
PEOPLE OR TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
INVESTMENT OUT OF CHILDREN'S OF
FUTURE OHIO EDUCATION.
COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
THE WORSE UP BILL INTRODUCED A
TO EXCUSE ORDERS CHILDREN THAT'S
THAT'S UP AGAIN A MEASURE PEOPLE
WERE.
THE PAY FOR TUITION AND THAT'S
THE REASON THEY END UP WITH THE
COTTAGES THAT SO WHEN THEY THEY
GRADUATE.
THIS PLAN IS A FIVE TWENTY NINE
IS EXCELLENT VEHICLE THAT WE
NEED GRUEL'S SO --
THE THE GROWTH AMOUNT.
OUR IS --
TAX EXEMPT HOWEVER THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO INVEST.
THIS IS SAW TO REDUCE THE FUTURE
COLLEGE THAT'S AND THE MORE
PEOPLE TO GET INVOLVED IN
PREPARATION FOR THE COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
SO THAT'S SO --
PERFECT A PROFIT.
PART OF PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP
AND THE TO LOWER THE FUTURE
EXPENSE HISSELF A PUBLIC --
I THOUGHT TYLER SO DOCTOR WE
HAVE TO I FOR THANK YOU I DOCTOR
CHOI AND THEN THAT WAS ACTUALLY
THREE FIFTY SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT ON AB.
TWO FIFTY HELLO TO THAT WAS.
TO I WAS THREE FIFTY YEAH SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON TWO
FIFTY AB.
TWO FIFTY YEAH AB.
TWO FIFTY AB TWO OF FIFTY IS SET
TO REVISE THE MINIMUM --
FRANCHISE TAX.
UNDER OUR CURRENT TAX LAW --
COMPANIES SELL COMPUTE DOT DATA
NET INCOME BY THE APPROPRIATE A
TAX RATE.
AND THE COMPARATOR TO THE
CURRENT MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX OF
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS SO WHICH
OF WHICHEVER AMOUNT IS SO HIGH
YOUR IS THE TAX THE PAY.
Y. L. ARE HAVING THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX UP ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA --
TO HAVE A MINIMUM THRESHOLD. FOR
TAXING CORPORATIONS.
THIS IS THE THRESHOLD IS SAW
DETRIMENTAL FOR SMALLER STARTUP
A CORPORATION.
OF WHO ARE JUST A GETTING ON THE
WAY.
HAVING A MINIMUM TAX OF FOR
CORPORATIONS REPORTING Là.
LO NET INCOME IS GOOD.
BUT DOT TREATING ALL LOW NET
INCOME CORPORATIONS THE SAME.
THAT IS WHY I'M PROPOSING TO
BASE THE OUR MINIMUM FRANCHISE
TAX SO WHEN THE GROSS RECEIPTS.
OF THE CORPORATION SO TO HELP
THE IN LEADERS STARTUP OF
CORPORATIONS ARE ARE OF KARAJ.
A GET THAT IS TO STOP THEIR HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
LIKE OUR OUR FAVORITE THE GARAGE
COMPANIES SELL UP FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY --
DID DOT AMAZONE MICROSOFT OR
APPLE.
DISNEY.
LOU THIS CYNICAL WATER AND A
HARLEY DAVIDSON.
OUT WITH ME TODAY AFTER GAVE
TESTIMONY AND SAW.
OUR ROBIN REPRESENTING THE A
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION SO TALK MORE ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU WITNESSES.
FOR CAN AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ROBIN
BLACK WITH THE CLIPS GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS.
I TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA --
AND WE'RE NOT.
I APOLOGIZE MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T GET A LETTER INTO THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE THE HEARING
TODAY AND SO.
DO APOLOGIZE --
MY PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY ILL
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS NOW.
AND SELL GIVEN THEM I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE --
WE THINK IT'S GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU CONSIDERING.
THE MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MEMBER
CORBIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION --
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE --
IT IS ANTICIPATED TO REDUCE THE
GENERAL FUND BY OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AS WRITTEN
WITHIN THE FIRST THREE YEARS I
HAVE 40% OF WHICH WOULD COME
DIRECTLY OUT OF KEY THROUGH --
FOURTEEN EXPENDITURES AND SO
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT SOMETHING
THAT HAS SUCH A LARGE PRICE TAG
CERTAINLY WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAYS THE BENEFITS --
WITH THE COSTS AND TO DATE NO
PROPONENT OF SUCH A MEASURE --
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PRESENT ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX IS A PROBLEM OF
BUSINESS FORMATION.
WITHOUT IT SHOULD BE LOWERED IN
FACT ACTUALLY HASN'T BEEN RAISED
SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY IN ADDITION AND
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT.
THAT INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T EVEN
NEED TO PAY THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO CONDUCT BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO
OPEN A BUSINESS AS A SOLE
PROPRIETOR SO THERE ARE MEANS TO
AVOID THIS EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR.
MINIMUM FEE --
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT SIMILAR
ISSUES INTRODUCED SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN NONE HAVE
PASSED THEIR HOUSE OF ORIGIN WE
WOULD LIKE TO THINK IT IS --
REFLECTIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
OPINION ON THE SUBJECT BUT
REGARDLESS ARE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ACCOUNTS ARE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN UNDER CHOI J. TO CLOSE.
YEAH AB --
TWO FIFTY OR SIMPLY CREATE A
MORE FAIR AND EQUITABLE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX A FULL CALIFORNIA
A SMALLER AND THE OFTEN YOU WILL
CORPORATION. TO PROMOTE THE
GROWTH AND THE AND TO APPROVE A
NEW WATER OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE
CORPORATIONS SO WE BEGIN
ACTUALLY BRING IN MORE REVENUE
BY ENCOURAGING --
THROUGH THIS SAW ENCOURAGEMENT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
AT THE AT THE TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR CHOI.
OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG ISLANDS.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS.
IN A FILE ITEM.
SEVEN AB FOR SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN SHE LIKED.
I THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
IS MY PLEASURE TO PRESENT.
AB.
FOR SIXTEEN THE BILL THAT WILL
PROVIDE A STATE TAX DEDUCTION TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO CONTRIBUTE TO
CAL ABLE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WHICH
ACCOUNTS THAT BENEFIT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN CONGRESS
PASSED THE ACHIEVING A BETTER
LIFE ACT WHICH ENABLES
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
TO OPEN TAX ADVANTAGED SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS THESE ACCOUNT ASIAN.
A MEDICAL CARE AND OTHER
EXPENSES RELATED TO LIVING WITH
A DISABILITY.
EACH STATE OPERATES THEIR OWN
ABLE PROGRAMS AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ALREADY OPENED
ACCOUNTS IN OTHER STATES.
AS A STATE WE WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER EVERY TOOL FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR LOVED ONES TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR OWN FINANCIAL STABILITY.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE
ACCOUNTS ARE AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN GIVING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES A CHANCE AT
INDEPENDENCE.
IMPORTANTLY ABLE COUNTS DO NOT
COUNT AGAINST A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES AGAINST A PERSON
WITH A DISABILITY ELIGIBILITY
FOR SSI.
I MEDICAID AND OTHER PUBLIC
BENEFITS.
THIS RECOGNIZES THE CHALLENGES
OF LIVING WITH A DISABILITY AND
THE AMOUNT OF CARE AND MONEY
THAT IS NEEDED THE SITUATION.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT IN
CLEAN TREASURER FIANNA Mà
FORMER CALIFORNIA STATE
TREASURER JOHN JOHN IN FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS THE DISABILITY
ABBASI COMMUNITY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY SUPPORT
IS THE MOTHER OF THE FIRST CAL
ABLE ACCOUNT OWNER.
KELLY CALLS ARRAY AS ALLEGED
ALICE REVIEW TREASURE IF YOU'RE
A MOP LIKE JOHNSON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN FONG FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY THANK YOU --
EVERYONE HEARS WHO'S HERE TODAY --
OUT. TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY
ABOUT MY SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR
SIXTEEN THE CAL ABLE TAX
DEDUCTION BILL.
THERE ARE MANY HIDDEN COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH RAISING A CHILD
WITH A DISABILITY.
AND THAT'S PART OF MY LIFE.
MANY FAMILIES HAVE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES AND CO PAYS FOR
EARLY INTERVENTIONS LIKE SPEECH
PHYSICAL AND OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE AMAZING
HABILITATED OF THERAPY COVERAGE
INSURANCE TYPICALLY COVERS.
ONLY IN CLINIC THERAPIES FOR A
FAMILY LIKE MINE.
THIS MEN'S DRIVING NINETY MILES
EACH WAY FIVE DAYS A WEEK AS OUR
INSURANCE DID NOT ALLOW FOR
BILLING MORE THAN ONE THERAPY
EACH DAY.
A HUNDRED EIGHTY MILES PER DAY.
NINE HUNDRED MILES PER WEEK FOR
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF OUR
DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE ENDEAVOR.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
FAMILIES ARE FACING EVERYDAY
FAMILIES LIKE OURS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE HIGH
LEVELS OF FINANCIAL STRESS.
THIS TAX DEDUCTION THE COW ABLE
TAX DEDUCTION WILL BE A
WONDERFUL INCENTIVE TO SAVE
WHILE REDUCING THE STRESS WE
EXPERIENCE EACH DAY. TEN STATES
HAVE ABLE STATE TAX DEDUCTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY HAVE MORE ACCOUNTS AND
MORE ASSETS THAN THE STATE'S
WITHOUT THEM.
STATE TAX DEDUCTIONS ENCOURAGE
SAVING.
PENNSYLVANIA HAS A STATE TAX
DEDUCTION FOR THE ENTIRE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THEIR ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
AND PENNSYLVANIANS HAVE ONE OF
THE LARGEST AVERAGE ACCOUNT
SIZES IN THE NATION.
CAL ABLE OPENED ON DECEMBER
SEVENTEENTH.
AND WE'VE SEEN A HUGE GROWTH AND
INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM.
AS OF MARCH TENTH CAL ABLE HAD
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
ACCOUNTS AND TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS AND
THIS NUMBER GROWS EACH WEEK.
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS THE HIDDEN COSTS OF
DISABILITY LOWER ANTICIPATED
EARNING POTENTIAL FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES LIKE MY
DAUGHTER.
AND ALL THE OTHER INEQUALITIES
THAT OUR DAUGHTER FACES THIS TAX
DEDUCTION IS A FIRST STEP.
TOWARDS PARITY FOR CAL ABLE
ACCOUNT OWNERS.
TODAY OUR DAUGHTERAMELIA IS A
BRIGHT AND SASSY SIX AND A HALF
YEAR OLD GIRL.
SHE'S SUCCESSFULLY INCLUDED IN
HER SCHOOL AND SHE IS THRIVING
WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
MORE MONEY FOR HER POST
SECONDARY OPTIONS FOR FUTURE
HOUSING AND HER FUTURE LIFE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW SHE WILL EXCEED
OUR HOPES AND OUR DREAMS AND OUR
EXPECTATIONS.
WE SIMPLY CAN'T DO THIS WITH OUR
CURRENT EARNING POTENTIAL.
IF WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMAN FONG'S
TAX A CALIBER BILL TAX DEDUCTION
BILL SIGNED INTO LAW WE AND
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
LIKE OURS.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO ENVISION A
FUTURE WITH LOWER LEVELS OF
POVERTY.
AND HIGHER LEVELS OF OPPORTUNITY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BLAKE JOHNSON
HER BEHALF OF TREASURE FIAMMA.
THE TREASURY THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIBER BOARD IS PROUD TO
SUPPORT A BEFORE.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
FOR THE SURPLUS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
A MESSAGE EARLIER A BEFORE
SIXTEEN WITHOUT A STATE TAX
DUCKS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING THIS STATE TAXES THAT
XIN WOULD LIKE RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS. FOR
QUALIFIED DISABILITY EXPENSES.
INCREASED PARK INCREASE
PARTICIPATION LOS ALLOWED THE
PLANTS RE SUSTAINABILITY IN A
QUICKER TIME FRAME --
AS A FAVORITE TWENTY TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE ARE FORTY PROGRAM
IN OPERATION. TEN OF WHICH
OFFERS STATEWIDE TAX DEDUCTION
FOR RESIDENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA ABLE PROGRAM
LAUNCHED IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS COMPETING
WITH OTHER STATES PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN OPERATION FOR OVER
TWO YEARS.
AND IF MARKETS ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS.
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE TO MAXIMIZE
INCENTIVES THAT INCREASE CALLIE
WITH PARTICIPATION.
AND ULTIMATELY ITS LONG TERM
VIABILITY AND SUCCESS.
THANKS FOR CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROB ON
BEHALF OF AUTISM SPEAKS AND THE
CENTER FOR AUTISM AND RELATED
DISORDERS AND SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BETH FOUR ACRE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL CATHOLIC
BOARD ON FULL INCLUSION WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
LIKE.
MY NAME IS CINDY LOU
REPRESENTING CLUB TWENTY ONE
LEARNING IN A RESOURCE CENTER WE
STAND IN SUPPORT I ALSO STAND AS
A PRIVATE CITIZEN IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I CURRENTLY HAVE A ABLE
ACCOUNT IN A DIFFERENT STATE.
HAPPY TO BRING IT OVER TO THIS --
ONE WITH THE RIGHT INCENTIVES SO
ENCOURAGE PASSAGE THANK YOU.
IN A PRESS HIM HAVE A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH SERVICES AT
HOME IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MOHAMMED TO STUDY AND
I SUPPORTED THROUGH BECAUSE I
HAVE A DAUGHTER IF YOU HAVE
SEVERAL POLICY.
MY NAME IS MANISHA STARRY AYE
MOHAMMED'S DAUGHTER AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE MY
OLDER SISTER STABLE POLICY HAS
TO GIVE UP MANY HOURS PER WEEK.
TRAVELING FROM OUR SIDE TO
DIFFERENT CITIES JUST TO GET THE
HEALTH CARE SHE NEEDS THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SINGING COMPETITIONS COMMITTEE
HAD TALKED QUIRK --
SO AGAIN MY PROBLEM HERE IS THAT
THE BIGGEST BENEFIT GOES TO THE
WEALTHIEST PEOPLE.
I'D MUCH RATHER SEE AN NEEDS
PROGRAM --
WE WE DEFINITELY UNDER FUND OUR
HELP TO THE DISABLED.
BUT HERE YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVE THE
HIGHEST INCOME IN THERE FOR WILL
GET THE BIGGEST TAX BREAK.
I WOULD RATHER A PROGRAM THAT
ACTUALLY GAVE MONEY TO PEOPLE
COULDN'T EVEN START A FIVE
TWENTY NINE AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE JUST A BETTER WAY TO
USE THE STATE'S MONEY SO AGAIN.
WE DO NEED MORE MONEY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS BUT I THINK IT SHOULD
BE DIRECTED BASED ON NEED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEN ON A
SIMILAR WHICH LIKE CLOTHES SURE
WOW JUST A FIRST MISTER QUIRK I
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO BENEFIT
ANYONE WITH THE PERSON.
WHO HAS A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES AND ALIVE SO
WHETHER YOU'RE LOW INCOME OR ARE
ARE ARE MIDDLE CLASS IS TO
ENSURE THAT YOU DO NOT LOSE YOUR
OR OTHER BENEFITS JUST BECAUSE
YOU NEED TO SAY FOR MORE?
COST ASSOCIATE WITH LIVING WITH
HIS WITH A DISABILITY THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED OF COURSE TO GIVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES A
CHANCE INDEPENDENCE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I THEM.
THANK YOU IT'S FOR TESTIMONY
ONLY TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO WHAT WAS THAT FILE
ITEM.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
[inaudible]
TWO FIFTY ONE YEAH.
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BE --
NEXT IN LINE SO.
WE HAVE SOME.
WITNESSES I BELIEVE THAT.
THE TESTIFIED ALL.
SO THEY'RE ON THE WAY.
WHICH ONE FIRST.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. FOUR TWO FIFTY
ONE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME --
TO PRESENT AB TWO FIFTY ONE THIS
WOULD PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT. TO
FAMILY CARE GIVERS UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES INCURRED WHILE
TAKING CARE OF LOVED ONES.
WITH CALIFORNIA'S SURGING
POPULATION OF OLDER ADULTS THE
STATE NEEDS TO DEVELOP WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE VAST NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT ACCOMPANY THIS --
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT.
MEMBERS OF THIS POPULATION
ESPECIALLY THOSE LIVING WITH
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS HAVE A
SICK SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THROUGH CARE GIVERS AND COMMONLY.
SUCH CARE GIVERS ARE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME
AND MONEY TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
LOVED ONES.
YET RECEIVE NO COMPENSATION FOR
THEIR OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES
SUCH AS MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
MEDICINE HALLMARK.
PATIENTS FOR EXCESS ABILITY AND
THE LIKE.
AB TWO FIFTY ONE WILL HELP TO
RELIEVE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
CARING FOR LOVED ONES IN
ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD HELP
CALIFORNIA PREPARE.
FOR RAPIDLY INCREASING
POPULATIONS OF OLDER ADULTS THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS MANY OF WHICH
WILL NEED A FULL TIME CAREGIVER.
THIS IS A TAX CREDIT
SPECIFICALLY AIMS TO BENEFIT THE
MIDDLE AND LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO OFTEN RECEIVE
LITTLE OR NO OUTSIDE HELP.
WITH --
WHILE TAKING CARE OF A FAMILY
MEMBER FULL TIME.
CALIFORNIA ONCE HAD A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR
FAMILY CARE GIVERS.
THAT CREDIT SUNSET IN.
TWO THOUSAND GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WE ARE FACING THIS IS
A CRUCIAL TIME TO BRING IT BACK
AND INCREASE THE CAP TO A MORE
IMPACTFUL AND MEANINGFUL AMOUNT.
THE MEDIAN ANNUAL COST OF
NURSING HOME CARE IS A
STAGGERING ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR.
IF WE INVEST A LITTLE BIT IN
HELPING FAMILY MEMBERS CARE FOR
LOVED ONES THIS WILL ULTIMATELY
SAVE A GREAT DEAL OF MONEY IN
THE LONG RUN.
BUT TODAY I HAVE WITH ME AT
DAVID FEINBERG CAPITAL RESPONSE
TEAM VOLUNTEER AND DISTRICT
LIAISON VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP.
AND MICHELLE TO BEAUTY --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE VALLEY
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER IN
FRESNO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IN
ASSISTANCE.
FOR THANK CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAVID FEINBERG ON NAY R.
P. VOLUNTEER.
ALL A. R. P. REPRESENTS THREE
POINT THREE THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE OVER THE
AGE OF FIFTY A. R. P. STAFF
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY ONE TO PROVIDE A TAX
CREDIT. FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
PROVIDING CARE AND SERVICES TO
THEIR LOVED ONES.
FAMILY CARE GIVING WHAT.
RUMORS LIKE ME.
HAVE NO CHOICE WE LOVE.
OUR LOVED ONES AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY SURVIVE.
MY STORY IS THAT OF A MOTHER WHO
IS NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD LIVING
IN A MEMORY FACILITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE COST FOR CARE
GOES BETWEEN NINE AND TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
DEPENDING ON YOUR SPECIFIC
MEDICAL NEEDS.
OF THAT HER INCOME OF TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH RECEIVES
FOR SOCIAL SECURITY IN A
VETERAN'S PENSION.
DOESN'T EVEN BEGIN TO COVER THAT
COST AN ADDITIONAL THREE TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS PAID BY
HOSPICE AGAIN THAT HELPS
MASSIVELY IN PROVIDING HER CARE
BUT THE REMAINING FOUR TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH PASSED
TO COME FROM SOMEWHERE.
AND SHE HAS NO OTHER ASSETS THAT
FALL THAT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
I SPEND MONTHLY WHICH I LOVE TO
DO IS TAKING MONEY OUT OF MY OWN
RETIREMENT PLAN SO THAT WHEN MY
WIFE AND I REACH THAT AGE AND
NEED THE CARE.
THE FUNDS THAT WE PUT AWAY WILL
BE THERE.
A A RP RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CARE GIVERS ON AVERAGE SPEND.
NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR OUT OF POCKET FOR EXPENSES
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES A A RP IS
ALSO FOUND THAT THOSE CARING FOR
SOMEONE WITH ALZHEIMERS OR
DEMENTIA CAN SPEND NEARLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
OVERALL CAL A. R. P. ESTIMATES
THAT THE ECONOMIC VALUE OF THE
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY
CALIFORNIANS NEARLY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CARETAKERS
EQUAL FIFTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
ANY ADDITIONAL HELP CALIFORNIA
TO PROVIDE THE FAMILY CARE
TAKERS LIKE MYSELF WOULD HELP TO
OFFSET THE LOSS TO OUR OWN
RETIREMENT INCOME AND SAVINGS.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE THE BOOTY ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR VALLEY
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER AND
FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ONE OF THE ELEVEN CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA SERVING OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CLIENTS IN NINE
COUNTIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM STANISLAUS TO KERN.
VALLEY CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER NONPROFIT AS ONE THE FEW
ORGANIZATIONS RECOGNIZING THE
PLIGHT OF FAMILY CARE.
IN PROVIDING SERVICES TO HELP
THEM THRIVE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY
AND SPEAK WITH YOU.
IF SOMEONE TOLD YOU THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
MOTHER WHO HAS DEMENTIA THEY
DON'T QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL.
AND A CAN OF FOR THE SEVEN TO
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR FACILITY OR IN HOME CARE HOW
WOULD WE RESPOND.
MY FAMILY PERSONALLY HAD TO
ADDRESS THESE QUESTIONS MY
PARENTS SAVE THEIR WHOLE LIVES
MY DAD HAD A LONG TERM CARE PLAN
MOM UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T QUALIFY.
MOM HAD DEMENTIA MOVED IN WITH
MY SISTER IT HAVE ADDITIONAL
HELP IN OUR HOME HOWEVER DAD HOW
TO SELL EVERYTHING HE HAD
INCLUDING THEIR HOME AND LIVE
VERY MODESTLY IN ORDER TO HELP
PAY FOR MOMS CARE.
THE WHOLE FAMILY DID HELP MY
SISTER HUSBAND DID ASK FOR ANY
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM BAD
BECAUSE JUST WASN'T ANY TO BE
HAD.
MY FAMILY SITUATION IS FAR FROM
UNIQUE IN FACT MEMORY FOR MANY
FAMILIES FIND IT MUCH HARDER
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING AT IT
ALONE OR DON'T HAVE AS MANY
RESOURCES.
IF YOU'VE EVER TAKING CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER OR SPOUSE YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THE GROWING ISSUES
THAT PLAGUE OUR SENIORS AND
THEIR FAMILY CARE GIVERS.
AND AS A COMMUNITY WE CAN NO
LONGER IGNORE THIS --
POPULATION IN EXACTLY WHO ARE
THESE CARE GIVERS THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVER ADULTS
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
PROVIDING EQUIVALENTLY ESTA ES
ESTIMATED FIFTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN CARE FOR LONG TERM
SERVICES.
THE OLDER CARE GIVERS HAVE A 63%
HIGHER MORTALITY RATE THAN ON
CARE GIVERS AND I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED THIS EVERY DAY IN MY
JOB. ONE IN FOUR CARE GIVERS ARE
MILLENNIALS FOR TRYING TO JUGGLE
SCHOOL AND WORK.
WITHOUT RESOURCES SUPPORT MANY
FAMILY CAREGIVERS FIND
THEMSELVES IN A STATE OF CRISIS.
VULNERABLE TO DEPRESSION ANXIETY
AND EVEN SUICIDE.
IS MY PERSONAL PROFESSIONAL
BELIEVE THAT AB.
TWO FIFTY ONE IS THE BEGINNING
OF RECOGNIZING ASSISTING THE
FINE.
IT WOULD NOT ONLY BENEFIT THE
CARE GIVER FINANCIALLY BUT ALSO
IMPACT THEIR WELL BEING THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BREAK NEBRASKA WE
HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR HEALTH SERVICES
AT HOME IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MET THE
CORPORATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION I'M WE DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PROBLEM THE
AUTHORS ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS IN
THIS --
CERTAINLY THE BURDEN OF FAMILIES
ON FAMILIES OF ADULT CARE CAN BE
QUITE COSTLY I'M WE DO DISAGREE
THAT THE PROBLEM CAN AND SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED THROUGH TAX CREDITS.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE COSTS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AS
IDENTIFIED BY THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD A SUCH A POLICY WOULD
SORELY DEPLETE THE GENERAL FUND
KEEPER FOURTEEN EDUCATION AS
WELL AS THE CRITICAL PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES ON WHICH AGENCY
AGING POPULATIONS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ASSIST --
DO RELY ONCE AGAIN THIS IS ALSO
A MEASURE THAT IS MOST LIKELY TO
REWARD THOSE WHO CAN IN FACT
ALREADY AFFORD --
TO SUPPLY THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES --
TO QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT THE
FAMILY CAREGIVER MUST HAVE
ADJUSTED INCOME OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AS AN
INDIVIDUAL FILER OR LESS THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
AS A JOINT FILERS --
IN ADDITION TO THAT --
THE THE MEASURE DOES NOT TAKE
ACCOUNT FOR WEALTH SO EVEN
THOUGH IT DOES HAVE A CAP WHICH
IS QUITE HIGH ON IT'S QUITE
POSSIBLE PERHAPS AS PEOPLE ARE
NEARING RETIREMENT FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THEY ARE.
OF SIGNIFICANT MEANS ON
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY BUT MIGHT
HAVE A A REDUCED INCOME --
THEY WOULD STILL OF COURSE BE
ELIGIBLE WITH UNFORTUNATELY
THOSE AT THE LOWEST END OF THE
INCOME SPECTRUM UNLIKELY TO SEEK
ANY SEE ANY BENEFIT --
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF COURSE WHO
DON'T ITEMIZE --
THE LA --
ALSO REVIEWED INFORMATION FROM
THE PREVIOUS --
CREDIT THAT THAT --
LAPSED AND SUNSET IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND FOUND THAT
CREDITS OF ALMOST TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION WERE CLAIMED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE TAX YEAR BUT OF
THOSE.
A 75% OF THE CLAIMANTS ACTUALLY
REPORTED AGI AN EXACT IN EXCESS
OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IT WAS
VERY VERY FEW --
AT LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED
TAXPAYERS WHO ACTUALLY HAD A
GROSS INCOME OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OR LESS --
AND THE KELLY --
CONCLUDED AT THAT TIME WHAT WE
BELIEVE WOULD BE TRUE OF THIS
MEASURE THAT THE CREDIT OPERATED
AS MORE OF A REWARD FOR THE CARE
PROVIDER RATHER THAN TO
INCENTIVIZE.
OR ENTERS OTHERS TO PROVIDE CARE.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE
MEASURE THINKING.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM ME DOT COM I
THINK YOU'RE MAKING A GENUINE
ATTEMPT TO MAKE THIS ARM TO
LIMIT THIS --
TO PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD THE
CARE AND IN THAT SENSE I THINK
IT'S YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB.
I WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS TIME
GOES ON BUT I THANK YOU FOR
THINKING ABOUT THIS THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY SOME COMMENTS.
THERE MADE ME ANALYSIS SHE'S
PROBABLY PAID BILL GOES ON THAT
I I THANK YOU FOR MAKING THIS
EFFORT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU KNOW I I AGREE WITH
DOCTOR KIRK --
I WANT TO THANK YOU YOUR BILL IS
ONE OF THE FEW IN COMPLIANCE
WITH SECTION FORTY ONE AND WITH
FIVE YEARS CENTS A DAY IN AND
YOU HAVE DONE CONTINUALLY WORKED.
TO MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT TIME AND THE
EFFORT.
WITH THAT.
THIS IS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
UP.
JUST A ARE APPRECIATED THE
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT --
TO THERE ARE A LOT LOWER INCOME
FOLKS AND ALL --
BUT THE FACT REMAINS THAT --
ANYONE REGARDLESS OF INCOME --
CAN.
APPLY AND QUALIFY FOR THIS --
THE OTHER REASON THAT WE SET IT
AT THE NUMBER THAT WE DID.
WAS BECAUSE OF THE RESEARCH
FOLKS.
DISCOVERED THAT SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR --
IT IS SORT OF THE THE TYPICAL
KIND OF OUT OF POCKET EXPENSE.
AND AGAIN THIS IS.
FOR THE KINDS OF PURCHASE IS
NECESSARY TO DO THE WORK --
OF CARING FOR THEM AS WELL --
OBVIOUSLY.
MODIFYING HOMES PUTTING STARED.
STARES IN --
TO GET AROUND STARES DEAD.
CONSTRUCT MAYBE SOME BATHROOMS A
IN CERTAIN WAYS SO.
BUT I ALSO WANTED --
TO BUT YOU KNOW I APPRECIATED
THE COMMENTS WITHIN --
THE STAFF REPORT --
OPEN TO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO UNDERSTAND.
THE PROCESS AND THE AREAS THAT
WE MAY NEED TO ADDRESS AND WE WE
WELCOME AND OUT THAT ANY TIME.
AND WITHOUT AYE I HOPE WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WHERE THIS
CANNELLA CAN BE VOTED ON IN
FAVOR THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL NUMBER
FIVE AB.
THREE TWENTY ONE YES TO SAY TO
SAY.
NOTHING BUT MY TWO BILLS ARE
BETTY COLLECTED.
WHERE ARE WILL TALK ABOUT TRUCKS
[inaudible]
AB.
I'M NOT SURE THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF AB THREE TWENTY ONE SEEMS A
SEEKS TO BRING.
PARITY. TO THE LAW REGARDING
TAXATION FOR COMMERCIAL TRUCKS
AND TRAILERS USED IN INTERSTATE
COMMERCE.
SO HERE'S CURRENTLY THE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR COMMERCIAL
TRUCK PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA TO
QUALIFY AS INTERSTATE COMMERCE
FOR TAX PURPOSES.
IT MUST MEET TO QUALIFICATIONS
IT MUST BE OUT OF THE STATE MORE
THAN 51% OF THE TIME.
AND THE VEHICLE MUST MAKE ITS
INITIAL TRIP WITH A LOAD.
INTO THE STATE.
EVEN IF IT WAS PURCHASED IN CAL
SO MANDATING THIS INBOUND TRIP
REQUIREMENT OBVIOUSLY INCREASES
POLLUTION THERE'S WEAR AND TEAR
ON ROADS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THIS
DISCOURAGES BUYERS FROM
PURCHASING THEIR COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY COMMERCIAL TRAILERS
USED IN INTERSTATE COMMERCE DO
NOT NEED TO MEET THIS INBOUND
TRIP REQUIREMENT.
AND INSTEAD MUST CONFORM TO PLAY
TO THE TRAILER IS USED IN
COMMERCE OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN 51% OF THE TIME AND
THAT THE TRAILER WILL LEAVE THE
STATE WITHIN SEVENTY FIVE DAYS
WITH ITS FIRST LOAD.
AB THREE TWENTY ONE SIMPLY SEEKS
TO APPLY THE SAME REQUIREMENTS
TO COMMERCIAL TRUCKS USED IN
INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
OF TO HELP EXPLAIN THE NEED FOR
A BI THREE TWENTY ONE AND TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT HERE IS LEE
HOWARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKS ENTERS [inaudible]
HI -- I'M WE
HOWARD I REPRESENT --
ONE THE LARGEST --
TRUCK DEALERSHIPS IN CALIFORNIA --
EACH DO H. HERE WE DELIVER AND
SELL PROBABLY ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
TRUCKS OUT OF MY FIVE DEALERSHIP
LOCATIONS THAT --
ARE GOING TO INTERSTATE COMMERCE --
THE FIRST LOAD IS THE REQUIRED.
OUTSIDE TRUCK BROUGHT INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
THESE TWO THOUSAND CUSTOMERS TO
BUY USED TRUCKS EVERY YEAR ALSO
TYPICALLY BY A TRAILER --
THAT CAN PICK IT UP AT THE
DEALERSHIP.
MEANWHILE WE HAVE TO DELIVER THE
TRUCK OUT OF STATE IN A NEVADA
ARIZONA --
ORGAN -- AND
THEN THEY HAVE TO AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S WHEN THE LEADING --
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES AND SO
WE EXPORT A LOT OF PRODUCTS OUT
OF CALIFORNIA BUT THIS THEY HAVE
TO BRING A LOAD IN THE
CALIFORNIA QUALIFY FIRST --
WE PRESENT WE SELL THE TRUCK TO
THE CUSTOMER IN CALIFORNIA AT
OUR DEALERSHIP AND IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO TAKE POSSESSION OF THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE TO THEN.
HAVE THEM TRAVEL UP TO THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES OUT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH BURNS ABOUT A FIFTY
GALLONS OF ADDITIONAL FUEL --
BEFORE THAT IT WITH AN EMPTY
TRAILER THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
HAUL ANYTHING --
WE THEN GO TO RISE THE SALE TOOK
PLACE IN THE STATE OF NEVADA
TRANSFER THE TRUCK BACK INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE TO PAY A DRIVER TO GO
OUT BOUND AND COME BACK.
THEY COME BACK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONLY TO TAKE THEIR
LOAD BACK OUT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO.
ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS GET
PARITY SO THAT WHEN THEY
PURCHASED THE TRACK AND THE
TRAILER WITH THE PROCESS AND DO
THE SAME THING --
TWO THOUSAND TRUCKS THAT WE SELL
IN A YEAR --
IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLONS OF DIESEL BOXES
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS
OF DIESEL BURNING CHIU EACH YEAR.
TAKE ALL THE OTHER DEALERSHIPS
AND IN THE STATE.
SPOT AN EXTRA HALF A MILLION
FUEL BURNED JUST BY HALF AND DO
THIS.
PROCESS WHICH REALLY IS.
NOT VIABLE IN TODAY'S WORLD SO.
ASK FOR SUPPORT AND THAT'S
CAROLINE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO SO IN THIS IS IN
SUPPORT.
MATT RIEMANN WITHOUT MY CHECKS
YOUTH TRUCKING ASSOCIATION --
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
DOCKS QUIRK.
I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER GOOD
BILL.
WHAT IS IN HIGH PRAISE TO AND
ONE DAY?
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OF WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE UP.
MY GOODNESS MISTER QUIRK GAVE MY
CLOTHES.
BUT YEAH I OBVIOUSLY FOR THE A
RECENT AS STATED --
OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT'S BURKE FUEL ALL OF THAT.
BUT IT DOES MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR THE PURCHASE TO
BE HERE.
AND IT TREATS THE TRUCK THE SAME
WAY THAT IT TREATS THE TRAILER.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF
EASY CALIFORNIA PURCHASED THAT
IS GOING TO BENEFIT THE STATE.
SO WHEN THE TIME COMES ASK FOR
OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO JOIN MISTER QUIRK IN
SUPPORTING THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB THIRTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
GET AFTER DENTURE WOMEN AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE 2% AB THIRTY ONE WHICH
ELIMINATES THE SALES TAX ON
MASTER PRODUCTS AND MAKES OUR
TAX COULD GENDER NEUTRAL THIS IS
THE ONLY SPECIFIC ONLY GENDER
SPECIFIC ITEM IN OUR TAX CODE
I'VE HAD.
THE LUXURY OF STUDYING THIS FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS TALKING
ABOUT MY PERIOD PUBLICLY FOR THE
LAST. FOUR YEARS --
IN CALIFORNIA THOSE OF US WERE
POORLY THEATER AS ARE BEING TAX
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE MINISTRY ON A
MONTHLY BASIS.
IT'S ARE NOT OUR LUXURY ARE
VALID SHE'S DEFINITELY NOT
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF OURSELVES TAX COULD AS A
REFLECTION OF WHAT WE VALUE.
IT'S HIGHLY VALUE WOMEN'S HEALTH
AND WE STOP TAXING MISTER
PRODUCTS.
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THE
STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO MEN
STRAIGHT.
WHO HAVE YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE PRODUCTS AND THEY GO TO
GREAT LANES YOU SEEN SOCKS
NEWSPAPER SIX AND IN THE LIFE OF
A PRODUCT AND?
RISKING INFECTION.
AT A MINIMUM AND WORSE FROM
THERE WE FOR FROM YOUNG GIRLS IN
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO MISS SCHOOL
OR MISS REGULAR ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE ADMINISTRATIVE AND KIND
OF FOR THESE PRODUCTS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM --
HOW HOMELESS WOMAN REPEALING THE
TAX WOULD MAKE THESE PRODUCTS A
LITTLE MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE
GROUPS FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD?
FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS FOR THE
HOMELESS.
BUT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
PUTTING A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY
IN OUR POCKETS OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN.
BUT IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE A TAX CODE THAT'S
REFLECTIVE OF A VALLEY'S ATTACKS
WITH THE DOESN'T SINGLE OUT HALF
OF THE POPULATION.
THE TAX SO THAT THE SOME BALANCE
THE BUDGET ON OUR UTERUS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND SO THE ANSWER TO DAY I HOPE
FROM ALL OF US THE TAX WITH
THAT'S FAIR AND GENDER NEUTRAL.
WHEN WE STARTED --
WILL BE VERY TAXING PRODUCTS IT
WAS A TIME WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
WAS COMPLETELY COMPRISED OF MEN.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE WEREN'T
TALKING ABOUT THEN AND UNTIL
RECENTLY WERE IN TALKING ABOUT
ANYWHERE.
SO NOT SURPRISING THAT THIS IS
FOR GOD AND AND OUR TAX CODE.
AND SO I HOPE THAT TODAY OR NOT
TO DAVE IN THE NEAR FUTURE WE
CAN GO AHEAD AND WITH THE
DISCUSSION FOR THE SICK SENATE
CARE MESSAGE THAT IN CALIFORNIA
WE VALUE RESPECT ALL ASPECTS OF
A WOMAN SOUTH.
AND OUR TAXES IF THE REFLECTION
OF THAT CALIFORNIA WAS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS WHO WERE THE
FIRST.
STATE IN THE NATION TO
INTRODUCED THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE FALLEN
BEHIND IN MORE THAN A DOZEN
OTHER STATES HAVE NOW PASSED.
A AND HAVE REPEAL THE TAX ON
THESE NATURAL PRODUCTS MOST
RECENTLY THE STATE OF NEVADA.
WITH ME I HAVE A SELFIE.
I SING.
MEMBER OF THE PAD PROJECT.
THE GROUP BEHIND THE OSCAR
WINNING DOCUMENTARY PERIOD END
OF SENTENCE.
AND MAY TO LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
IN THE ACTIVISTS SHE AND HER
TWIN SISTER ALLEN OUR FOUNDERS
OF THE GRASSROOTS MOVEMENTS TO
AND THE TAX ON TOP.
ON TAMPONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RACHEL LEE AND MY TWIN SISTER
HELEN LEE AND I OR LIFELONG
ADVOCATES FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH AND
DENTAL EQUITY.
STRONG BELIEVERS IN AB THIRTY
ONE AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
BASED IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE SPEARHEADED
THE MOVEMENT TO END THE
REGRESSIVE SALES TAX ON PADS
TAMPONS AND MITCHELL CUPPED IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALTERED THE ORIGINAL PETITION
ON CHANGE DOT ORG WHICH GARNERED
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND
SIGNATURES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY ONE FOR A DIALOGUE TO DE
STIGMATIZE MENSURATION AND
PARTNER WITH SCHOOLS AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCREASE
ACCESSIBILITY TO NATURAL
PRODUCTS. 93% OF OUR SIGNERS
HAVE STATED THAT THEIR BIOLOGY
SHOULD NOT HAVE THEM SUBJECT TO
SEXIST UNNECESSARY TAXATION FOR
NECESSARY BODILY FUNCTION.
PADS AND TAMPONS PREVENT HEALTH
RISKS SUCH SUCH AS INFECTIONS
AND ALLOW WOMEN TO PERFORM DAY
TO DAY TASKS WITHOUT BEING
BURDENED BY THE WEIGHT OF THEIR
BIOLOGY.
ACCORDING TO THE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION ONE IN TEN WOMEN AND
GIRLS OF MEASURING AGE LIVE
UNDER THE POVERTY LINE IN
CALIFORNIA.
POVERTY ALREADY MAKES THIS
REGRESSIVE TAX BURDEN SOME TO
PAY FOR THOSE MUCH CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE HYGIENE.
AND A MEAL.
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA SALES
AND USE TAX EXEMPTIONS AND
EXCLUSIONS CODE P. FOUR TO FIVE
SECTION FIVE TWO TWO EXEMPTS
NECESSITIES FROM LIVE THAT ARE
HEALTH RELATED. FOR SOME REASON
ITEMS SUCH AS LUBRICATING JELLY
AND BY AGGRO OR ACCEPT FROM THIS
LAW HOWEVER MITCHELL HOW YOU
POLITICS OR NOT.
THIS IS AN INJUSTICE THAT GROUP
DOES PERSUASIVE AND SYMBOLIC OF
THE OUTDATED SYSTEMS AND LAWS
THAT WE FACE ON A DAY TO DAY
LEVEL. FOUR YEARS AGO A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WE BEGAN A
PETITION TO BRING TO LIGHT THE
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF SUCH
SYSTEMATIC SEXISM AND
LEGISLATION.
TODAY WE STAND WITH THE MANY
ACTIVISM WHO HAVE COME TOGETHER
TO FORM THE AND THE TAMPON TAX
IN CALIFORNIA STEERING COMMITTEE.
TOGETHER WE HAVE GARNERED OVER A
HUNDRED AND FOUR GROUPS THAT
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA NOW INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IS A MATTER OF SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND WE CALL
LEGISLATORS LIKE YOU.
WHO HAVE THE POWER TO EMPOWER
GENERATIONS OF WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA BY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU?
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SOPHIA ASH TIME AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY ONE I'M A CO FOUNDER THAT
HAD PROJECT A NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOUNG WOMAN
FROM A CALIFORNIA IN INDIA.
THAT WHAT IS IT THAT RECENTLY
WON AN OSCAR FOR DOCUMENTARY
PERIOD END OF SENTENCE FOR A
WORK ON DOT TO BREAK MENTIONED
HAVE USE AND TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND HYGIENIC NATURAL
PRODUCTS FOR ALL.
MY FRIENDS AND I STARTED THE POD
PROJECT BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPACT THIS LACK OF ACCESS TO
MUCH FOR PRODUCTS CAN HAVE ON A
CHILD'S EDUCATION AND SUCCESS IN
LIFE.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE LACKS THE OPPORTUNITIES
WE'VE ENJOYED JUST BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD OR ACCESS THESE
PRODUCTS.
THE WORK IS MOSTLY FOCUSED ON
THE GREAT DISPARITY IN INDIA
WE'VE COME TO UNDERSTAND HOW
PROBABLY THESE ISSUES ARE
GLOBALLY.
INCLUDING UNITED STATES AND OUR
HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT TAX CODE --
ON AND FOR PRODUCTS AS A GENDER
TAX THE PROFITS OF INSURERS OR
SOMETHING ENTIRELY OUT OF OUR
CONTROL. FOR THOSE OF US WHO CAN
AFFORD IT THIS TAX IS A NUISANCE
DURING ALREADY KNOWING TIME BUT
FOR LOW INCOME AND HOW MUCH
FUNDS TRADERS THIS TAX ME THE
DIFFERENCE.
BETWEEN THE ABILITY TO AFFORD
THESE NECESSARY PRO I'M WOMAN
WHO IS PROUD TO THE ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST FORWARD THINKING
STATES I'M CONTINUALLY
DISHEARTENED BY OUR CURRENT TAX
CODE WHICH IS NOT REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESSIVE VALUES.
AB THE POSITIVE A. B. THIRTY ONE
RECTIFY THIS BY LIVING IN SOUTH
TALK SO MUCH TO PRODUCTS.
AB THIRTY ONE ELIMINATES ONE
MORE BARRIER TO NON
DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS METROPARKS
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE TIME
COMES I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MEMBERS MY JORDAN I'M WITH AND
THE TâM ON TAX IN CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND ALL RISE ALAMEDA.
SCHERING GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR ANDRE CAN TERRA WITH THE
CITY OF AMANTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HYPHEN LOWER AKA IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE FROM ALAMEDA NASTY
WOMAN.
EILEEN SONG ON BEHALF OF THE
NIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MARSHA SORRY I MISSED
YOU NOT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF OUR IGNITE NATIONAL
CHOPPED AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HALEY EGGMAN AND I GO
TO SEE YOUR COLLEGE AND WALKING
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RYAN TWO STORY AND I
ORDERED ON REGIONAL SCHOOL AND A
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A LEASE LEAST AREAS
ALSO STATE I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOE ON ALL OVER IS
I'M A STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
AND A PARTICIPANT IN IT IN THE
NIGHT.
AND I'M ORIGINALLY FROM THE
POOREST COUNTY IN ONE OF THE
POOREST COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KATHLEEN MEGAN AND
I DROVE HERE FOR THREE HOURS
WITH BUYING THAT COHORT FROM
CAPRINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A QUICK HELTON I GO
TO CAREER COLLEGE AND I'M UP ON
A BOARD OF A IGHT NATIONAL AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE MY
MOTHER USED RAGS AND TOILET
PAPER WHEN SHE WAS MENSTRUATING.
I MEAN I SHOT OVER ME DOES I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE
HER HER HERS I AM A PART OF IT
MAY AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MEGAN MICHAEL BERGEN
I'M IT STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HANNIBAL ECONOMIST IN
THE UC DAVIS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARE OF THE ENEMY
SENIOR UC BERKELEY A MEMBER THAT
NIGHT I FACILITATE YOUNG HIGH
SCHOOL GIRLS AND MANY OF THEM
CAN'T AFFORD MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS.
AND SOME STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CLEAR IS A HER
BREEDER AND I AM A STUDENT
CARILLO COLLEGE IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY -- I
AM THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY
CHAIR OF CAPRI WITH NATE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHEYENNE LOFTIS I AM
A REAL COLLEGE STUDENT FROM
SANTA CRUZ AS WELL AS A NIGHT
MEMBER.
AND SANTA CRUZ IS THE FOURTH
MOST EXPENSIVE CITY IN THE
NATION AND SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS WAY WAY TEN I GO
BASE YOU HERS I'M A SENIOR AT UC
DAVIS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE PERIOD AT UC DAVIS CHAPTER
OF THE NATIONAL.
YOUTH RUN NONPROFIT PERIOD AND
WE HAVE HAD A SURVEY OUT FOR THE
STUDENTS STUDENTS WHO RESPONDED
SAID THAT. SIX OF THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S MINIONS ALL AS I'M
A STUDENT I UC DAVIS AND A
MEMBER OF PERIOD AT UC DAVIS AND
PART OF THE PAYMENT ORG THANK
YOU I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS BROOKE PRITCHARD
I'M A STUDENT AT UC DAVIS ALSO
MEMBER OF AT NIGHT I JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT I CAME HERE DURING
FINALS WEEK IS IS SO IMPORTANT
TO ME.
SO I URGE YOU STRONGLY TO VOTE
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A RUSSIAN AMEND I'M A
FIRST YEAR STUDENT AT UC DAVIS A
MEMBER OF THE DAVIS COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS KAYLA AND THE STUDENT
AT UC DAVIS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY JO NOON YES I'M
A STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND A
MEMBER OF AT NIGHT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARISSA GONZALEZ I'M
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNA FORTNEY I AM A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SYLVIA YOUNG AND I
AM WITH THE NO TAMPON TAX.
IN CALIFORNIA COALITION I AM
ALSO AN ENDOMETRIOSIS PATIENT
ADVOCATE AND I REPRESENT ONE IN
TEN WOMEN WHO MEANT STRAIGHT
MORE THAN ONCE A MONTH.
SO THIS IS A REALLY UNFAIR TAX --
AND I SUPPORT THE SPELL.
HI I'M TIFFANY ONLY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JESSICA BARTH LOW WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND ALSO ON
THE BOARD OF THE NATIONAL TYPE
BURBANK NETWORK WHICH RUNS THE
ALLIANCE FOR PAIRED SUPPLIES.
AND SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SELF IN HIRSCH I
AM ON THE AND THE TAMPON TAX
COMMITTEE AND I ALSO HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPLIES
REUSABLE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. TO
LOW INCOME AND TRADERS IN LOS
ANGELES.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HELEN LEE --
TWIN SISTER ORIGINALLY AND THEN
THE CO FOUNDER OF THE
INDEPENDENT ACTIVISTS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE'VE GIVEN
NINE HOURS FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS TO SUPPORT THE PAST
ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS COOLEY TO SEE
GOING ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL REALIZATION
FOR WOMEN.
IN ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
IN THE TEMP TEMP CONTACTS
COALITION WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WILL HOW MUCH YOUR
STUDY ON FROM THE STOCK AND I
HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RENTS SPENCER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS IN SPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
CHAIR MEMBERS MEET THE CORPORATE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
I THINK OF ALL OF THE BILLS THAT
WE OPPOSE IN THIS COMMITTEE THIS
ONE MIGHT MAKE ME THE MOST
UNPOPULAR OF ALL OF THEM --
BUT THAT SAID LET'S TALK IT
THROUGH A LITTLE BIT.
WINDS IN CALIFORNIA'S TAX CODE
ARE ARE FREQUENTLY AND OFTEN
ARBITRARILY DOT DRAWN EVEN IN
INSTANCES OF SO CALLED NECESSITY
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE
EXAMPLES. FOR EXAMPLE WE DON'T
TAX FOOD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT ALSO
INCLUDES CANDY WHICH ARGUABLY
NOT A NECESSITY WE DO HOWEVER
TAX TOILET PAPERS.
AS ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE DON'T TAX
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION IF THE
DOCTOR HAS PRESCRIBED IT BUT THE
SAME MEDICATION IF PURCHASED
OVER THE COUNTER WE WOULD IN
FACT TAX --
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
DON'T MAKE A LOT OF SENSE IN
CALIFORNIA'S TAX CODE.
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST MEASURE
THAT WE AND THAT WAS ON THE
BASIS OF GENDER SPECIFICALLY AND
INTENTIONALLY BUT THEN IT ALSO
BEGS A LOT OF OTHER QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES FOR
EXEMPTIONS THAT FOLLOW FOR
EXAMPLE COSMETICS CLOTHING
CLOTHING ARGUABLY BRAS ARE
SOMETHING THAT WOMEN DO IN FACT
NEED -- BUT
THEY ARE TAXED.
AND THEN --
OTHER OVER THE COUNTER --
PHARMACEUTICALS --
THINGS LIKE CONTRACEPTIVES
CONDOMS OVER THE COUNTER BIRTH
CONTROL ARGUABLY SHOULD THESE BE
TAXED -- IN
ADDITION TO THAT.
LET'S WALK THROUGH.
THE SAVINGS I'M SO WAIT A FIFTY
CAL BOX OF TAMPONS ASSUMING IT'S
A REGULAR SIZE TAMPON TAMPAX
PEARL TODAY WOULD COST NINE
DOLLARS AND THIRTY NINE CENTS AT
TARGET.
AIMING A 6% STATE SALES TAX THIS
MEASURE IF PASSED WOULD SAVE
REGARDLESS OF NEED FIFTY SIX
CENTS.
PER BOX ASSUME ONE BOX PER MONTH
IT WOULD SAVE UNDER SEVEN
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR YOUR PROBABLY
AVERAGE CONSUMER SO IN ESSENCE
NOT ENOUGH TO BUY ANOTHER BOX OF
TAMPONS --
HOWEVER THE COST TO THE STATE OF
IMPLEMENTING SUCH A MEASURE
WOULD BE ABOUT APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
EIGHT MILLION OF WHICH ANNUALLY
WOULD BE A DIRECT HIT TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION --
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN OBVIOUSLY IS
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME HER A. B. TEN ON TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I THINK IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW.
YOU CAN.
REDUCE THE BURDEN ON CERTAIN
POPULATIONS OF WOMEN --
THAT MEASURE --
FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR
WITH IT ACTUALLY THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CERTAIN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT MET VARIOUS POVERTY
THRESHOLDS HAD FUNDING TO SUPPLY
THESE TYPE OF PRODUCTS TO
STUDENTS IN NEED --
AND SO WE ARE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS MEASURE
WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD BUT WOULD
ENCOURAGE HER --
TO CONTINUE TO CONSIDER OPTIONS
SIMILAR TO AB TEN WHERE THOSE
MOST IN NEED --
CAN NOT ONLY GET A BENEFIT BUT A
BENEFIT THAT WOULD REALLY BE
MEANINGFUL --
RATHER THAN ONE THAT WOULD SAVE
WOMEN ACROSS THE STATE THE
EQUIVALENT OF SEVEN DOLLARS A
YEAR THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
AND THE COMMITTEE.
ANYBODY.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION --
BASICALLY I GUESS YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND MY PREDECESSOR FOR
SMALL AS A MAN --
AND DIDN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION AS A WOMAN
CHAIR.
CLEARLY SIXTY CENTS OR WHATEVER
YOU CALCULATED WE GET SOME
PEOPLE GET TO SIXTY CENTS SOME
PEOPLE GET TO EIGHTY CENTS
SAVINGS A MONTH.
NOT ENOUGH TO MAKE.
NOT ENOUGH TO BUY AN EXTRA BOX
OF THE YEAR OR NOT ENOUGH
OBVIOUSLY TO CHANGE WHETHER YOU
CAN WHAT YOU CAN AND CANNOT
PURCHASE.
SO FOR YOU IS THIS A IS THIS.
GENDER EQUITY ISSUE OR IS THIS A
FINANCIAL ISSUE.
BOTH -- I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
DECIDING IF EIGHTY SENSITIVE
ENOUGH OR NOT I HAVE FOLKS OUT
THERE WAS JUST.
ACTUALLY HAVING A DISCUSSION
WITH.
SOMEBODY ABOUT HOW WHEN I WAS
SICK MY SISTER NICE TO PULL OUR
MONEY TOGETHER TO BUY WHEN THOSE
LITTLE TINY BAGS OF CHIPS AND
WITH A QUARTER --
AND SO.
PICK UP PENNIES WHATEVER I WAS
LIKE WE'RE GONNA HAVE THIS KNACK
INSTILLED THAT TWENTY FIVE CENTS
AND LIKE THE WORLD TO AS IT ALSO
MEANT THAT MAYBE I GOT TWO OF
THE PULL THAT DAY YOU KNOW AND
SO.
I THINK IT'S UP TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON A LIMITED
BUDGET FOR THEM THAT EIGHTY
SINCE MY MEAN A LOT AND EIGHTY
CENTS.
A DOLLAR I MEAN IT VARIES BY
EIGHT BY HELPFUL INDIVIDUALS.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
DRAWING THE LINE OF WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IF I WOULD USE THAT SAME
LOT LOGIC TO SAY THAN THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE USE IS
THE PORTABLE.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT ON THE LINE I
WANNA I WANNA TALK THAT THE
OPPOSITION THEY TALKED ABOUT.
DRAWING THE LINE IN IN A GENDER
SPECIFIC THIS IS THE ONLY GENDER
SPECIFIC ITEM IN OUR TAX CODE.
THIS IS THE ONLY THING THAT SAYS
THAT MY UTERUS ON BORN WITH THE
UTERUS AND AYE MAINSTREET EVERY
MONTH FOR FORTY YEARS OF MY LIFE.
IS A LUXURY THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
AND I THOUGHT SELECT THAT AND WE
TALKED ABOUT COSMETICS AND
CLOTHING NOT ESSENTIALS.
PLACENTALS IKE ADVOCATE DISS HAS
BEEN DOING THE MEDICAL NECESSITY
AND NOW HE SOUTH LOOKS LET'S
TAKE A MONTH FOR THE NEXT MONTH
EVERYONE THE MINISTRY SO THAT
WHICH OPERATING GO AHEAD AND
HAVE THAT BLOOD.
STAIN EVERYWHERE ON AND YOU KNOW
LET'S ALSO NOT SHAVER LIFT UP
AND MAKE UP THE EFFECTS ARE NOT
THE SAME THE REALITY IS NOT THE
SAME OUT THERE WE SHOULD HAVE A
GENERAL INTEREST TAX CODE AND
IT'S ALSO ABOUT SAVINGS FOR
THOSE FOLKS AND THEY COULD DIEM
HOW TO BEST.
USE WHETHER IT'S A QUARTER OR
TWO DOLLARS YEP LOOKS AT THE
TIME BUT THEY'RE BUYING
INDIVIDUAL TAMPONS OUR PRODUCT
OF THE TIMES THAT'S ALL THEY
COULD AFFORD THAT AND THEY HAVE
TO STRETCH OUT I TO MAKE IT WORK.
AND CITING COMING FROM A
POSITION OF PRIVILEGE AND SAYING
EIGHTY CENTS IS NOT A LOT IS NOT
A GOOD ENOUGH EXCUSE FOR ME NOT
TO GET RID OF THIS TAX.
NOT YET IN A DEBATE ON THE
CONVERSATION BUT I MEAN.
WE DO WORK IN PA I WILL WORK AND
POVERTY REGULARLY AND IT'S NOT A
COMMENTED AS TOO LATE WHETHER
SIXTY OR FORTY OR FIFTY CENTS OR
EIGHTY CENTS IS ENOUGH.
THE QUESTION IS IS THAT.
IS THAT FOR A YOU OR ME OR OR AB
MIDDLE CLASS INDIVIDUAL ENOUGH
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND ARE WE BEING TARGETED ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION.
I AND THAT'S WHY MY QUESTION IS
VERY GENUINELY.
IS IS THIS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THIS IS THE ONLY PRODUCT.
THAT IS TAX THAT IS A WOMAN ONLY
PRODUCT OR IS THIS ABOUT THE
TWENTY FOUR IN TO EIGHTY CENTS --
BECAUSE FOR A LARGE PORTION OF
THE POPULATION AND YOU KNOW I I
IT IS THAT THAT SIXTY CENTS
DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING THAT
EIGHTY CENTS DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
THOSE WHO BY INDIVIDUAL TAMPONS
ARE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY CAN
AFFORD AT THAT MOMENT.
HOWEVER I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATION DIFFICULTY WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS THAT IT
DOESN'T IT ISN'T JUST FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IT'S FOR EVERYBODY.
AND IS NOT JUST A CHAIR BUT AS A
WOMAN CHAIR I CAN UNDERSTAND.
THAT THIS THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
PRODUCT THAT ONLY WOMEN USE AND
THAT IT IS NOT SHOCKING TO ME ON
ANY LEVEL.
THAT THIS WOULD BE THE ONE
PRODUCT THAT WOULD BE TAXED AND
WE'RE OTHERS WOULDN'T BUT I
WANTED TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
INTENTION WAS AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND IT.
CLEARLY BOTH I HAVE A HASHTAG
GENDER EQUITY AS IT IS ABOUT
GENDER EQUITY AND THE TAX CODE --
AND SO I WOULD LIKE A TAX CODE
THAT.
REFLECTS THE VALUES THAT.
NO MATTER IF I'M LOW INCOME
MIDDLE INCOME OR HIGH INCOME MY
UTERUS IS NOT A LUXURY.
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT A LUXURY
THERE'S NOT A HAPPY HOUR I WOULD
LOVE TO TAX CANDY AND SNACKS
I'VE TRIED IT MULTIPLE TIMES
THAT WOULD LOVE TO TAX.
COCKTAILS --
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WHILE WE GET
THE POLITICAL WILL OF HOW WE
REFORM ARE GROW THE TAX BASE.
I WOULD LIKE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IMMEDIATELY
PRESS TO HAVE A GENERAL NEUTRAL
TAX CODE IT'S ABOUT THE MESSAGES
VERY SENDING ABOUT WOMEN'S
HEALTH AND WOMEN'S BIOLOGY ASAL
HOLE A RESPECTIVE OF OUR INCOME.
THANK IN PEACE IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO ME AND SO FROM IS ABOUT TO
SEE ONE OR THE OTHER AND I
HAVEN'T BEEN SHY ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT GENDER EQUITY.
AROUND THIS ISSUE AND THE AND
COMMISSION ALSO COMES INTO PLAY
BUT IF YOU WANT ME TO BREAK IT
DOWN TO ONE I THINK EITHER
MERITS A YES VOTE WHEN THIS IS
UP FOR A VOTE --
HOWEVER YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT IT.
DR COURT DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION
OR INTENT.
SUPPOSE WE WERE TO JUST TAX MORE
MALE PRODUCTS IN THAT WOULD EVEN
IT OUT.
I WOULD LIKE I I WOULD HAVE TO
SAY NO TO THAT BECAUSE I NEED IF
I AM FOR GENDER EQUITY HAVE BOTH
SIDES -- AND
SO I I YOU KNOW WELL I THINK
THAT THAT INNOVATIVE.
IN ALL FAIRNESS I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR TO ME TO SAY SUDDENLY
IN THE SAME WAY THAT I'M ASKING
THAT WE DON'T SINGLE OUT.
THE THE THE PEOPLE VIOLENT THE
UTERUS I DON'T WANT TO SINGLE
OUT.
SOMEONE WORKING WITH THE ****.
WITH THAT AND IT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I THIS IS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE --
I JUST LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
AND THE IN THIS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION ARE ON MINSTREL
EQUITY IS JUST A SMALL PART IN
IN THE DISCUSSION OF HOW WE SEE
WOMEN HOW WE SEE OUR BIOLOGY OUT
THERE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BUT
WHEN IT'S TIME AND I THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ENGAGING IN THIS
CONVERSATION I KNOW THE TOPICS
NOT ALWAYS COMFORTABLE.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
PERIODS AND I ALWAYS LEAVE YOU
WITH THIS IT'S IT'S NOT A?
BLUE PRODUCT AND WE'RE NOT
RUNNING TO FEELS EVERYMONTH
WHEN WE GET OUR PERIOD OUT THERE --
AND SO THIS IS THE REALITY THAT
WE LIVE WE LIVE IN AN PART OF
GETTING RID OF THE NATURAL --
TABOO THAT IS OUT THERE TALKING
ABOUT IT OPENLY FIRE SEXUALLY --
AND THANKFULLY US I'M SORRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUT WHEN
IT'S TIME AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE SPACE TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSION WELL ABSOLUTELY
LESSEN THE DISCOMFORT IT'S GIVEN
MY COMMITTEE STAFF HAS BEEN JOY
ENOUGH FOR ME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
NINE AB.
FOUR NINETY TWO ROSE MARIE
REALLY INTO AND THAT SHE THE
LAUGHING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH YOU LIKE
TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB FOR
NINETY TWO MY OFFICE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
COMPLY.
WITH THE COMMITTEES TAX
EXPENDITURE POLICY --
A BEFORE NINETY TWO WILL EXPAND
TO HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS
PROPERTY TAX ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE ALL LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF AGE
OR DISABILITY.
THE HOMEOWNER AND RENTERS
SYSTEMS PRO LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND DISABLED HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS IT PROVIDES A PARTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT OF PROPERTY TAXES
PAID.
FOR THEIR PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE IN
THE PRIOR YEAR UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS
FOR HOMEOWNERS AND THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS. FOR
RENTERS THIS BILL SIXTY SEEKS TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM TO ALL LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN FACING A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND
IS DRIVING MORE CALIFORNIANS
INTO POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS.
MORE THAN HALF OF RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS IN OUR STATE PAY MORE
THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOMES TOWARD
HOUSING.
MAKING THEM HOUSING COSTS
BURDENED AND NEARLY A THIRD ARE
SEVERELY COST BURDENED PAYING
MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR INCOMES
TOWARD HOUSING.
THESE FOLKS ARE ALREADY MAKING
TOUGH DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO
PAY RENT OR BUY GROCERIES.
AND THESE YEARLY REIMBURSEMENTS
WILL HELP TO SUBSIDIZE A PART OF
THEIR FINANCES.
BY FIVE BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
THIS PROGRAM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CAN TAKE ANOTHER CRITICAL STEP
TO FURTHER MITIGATE THE CURRENT
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS SUSIE
SHANNON WITH POVERTY MATTERS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
I'M CZ SHANNON I AM A HEALTH
COMMISSIONER WITH CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF POVERTY MATTERS.
AND MY ORGANIZATION PROVIDES
DIRECT SERVICES AND POLICY
ADVOCACY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS --
AS WELL AS LOW INCOME RENTERS
CLIENTS.
HAVE INCOMES BELOW THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS --
AND WE ARE VERY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB --
FOUR NINETY TWO WHICH PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE FOR HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS --
REGARDLESS OF DISABILITY OR AGE --
AS YOU HEARD THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATE WHERE ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS --
I SEE THIS EVERY DAY AND LOS
ANGELES IS ARGUABLY THE HOMELESS
CAPITAL OF THE UNITED STATES AND
SHARES THAT.
A TITLE --
WITH NEW YORK --
AND I WORK WITH LOW INCOME
RENTERS WHO ARE ON THE VERGE OF
HOMELESSNESS --
AND WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
PEOPLE WHO ARE RENT BIRD AND
WHAT WE DON'T HEAR A LOT ABOUT
ARE THE STORIES.
OF FROM LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO BUY FOOD --
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON TO PURGE
AIDS --
SOCKS AND SHOES AND GETTING JUST
BASIC TRANSPORTATION TO DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENTS AND SOMETIMES JUST
THAT LITTLE BIT --
CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
GETTING INTO A DOCTOR AND NOT
GETTING TO A DOCTOR --
SO FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR THIS
POPULATION COMMUNE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BUYING FOOD
AND GOING HUNGRY AND IF
SOMETIMES PARAMOUNT TO THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE --
FOR THOSE WHOSE INCOMES ARE AT
OR BELOW THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
AND THEN ONE OTHER THING THAT
I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN JUST OVER
THREE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA --
HAD EARNINGS AT OR BELOW THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ASSISTANCE
FOR THOSE IN THIS INCOME BRACKET --
INCREASES CONSUMER BUYING POWER
POWER FOR ESSENTIAL ITEMS AND
THAT MONEY GOES DIRECTLY INTO
THE LOCAL ECONOMY CAN ALSO ACT
AS AN ECONOMIC STIMULUS.
SO IF YOU'RE NOT MOTIVATED BY
THE HUMANITARIAN ARGUMENT --
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER ON
THAT PARTICULAR ASPECT AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU'LL SUPPORT AB FOUR
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
JIM HAMMER WITH HOW.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIM CAMERA
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC ADVISERS ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS OF
SOUTHERN CITIES AN APARTMENT SO
SEASONS OF ORANGE COUNTY WE
SUPPORT AND WE JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING
THIS AND REMINDING US AS WE DEAL
WITH THIS HOUSING CRISIS THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY POLICIES
THEY'RE ALREADY ON THE BOOKS
THAT ARE LAW.
THEY JUST NEED A BIT MORE
FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS OUR YOUTH SUPPORTER
OF WE'RE ADD TWEENER AT THIS
TIME WE'RE STILL CONTEMPLATING
OUR POSITION I'M WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD?
IT'S PLAUSIBLE THAT WE COULD GET
TO SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE
HOWEVER WE DO NEED TO HAVE A FEW
MORE CONVERSATIONS AND DO SOME
SUBSEQUENT ANALYSIS TO JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD AND FOR YOUR OFFICE
FOR REACHING OUT --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE YES
START QUIRK --
SO MY MY REAL QUESTION ON THIS
YEAR'S PARTICULARLY IN THE
AMOUNT FOR A HOMEOWNER.
CAN THIS REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
PERHAPS YOUR EXPERT OR YOU CAN
ADDRESS THAT.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE VERY SMALL
AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
OUT OF GIVE A BRIEF ANSWER BUT
I'D LIKE --
MISSION INTO RESPOND AS WELL
GIVEN THAT SHE ON A DAILY BASIS
IS WORKING ON THESE ISSUES AND
HAS FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE --
I I I THINK WE HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF A LIFE THAT.
ALLOWS US TO NOT CONTEMPLATE.
HOW THAT LITTLE AMOUNT?
COULD HAVE AN IMPACT --
BUT ON A DAILY BASIS WE SEE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MAKING
DECISIONS.
BASED ON MORE SOULS AND CRUMBS
OF WHAT THEY HAVE TO WORK WITH --
WITH THAT.
I'D SAY THE ANSWER IS A DEFINITE
YES -- I
WORKED WITH.
SOME OF THE CLIENTS THAT I WORK
WITH WHO ARE ACTUALLY RENTERS --
WILL BRING IN LOOK IN INCOME OF
LESS THAN THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT THERE AND GENERAL RELIEF --
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
WHICH WERE THE ONLY GET TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DOLLARS A
MONTH THIS IS.
REALLY HE IN A LOT OF SITUATIONS
IT COULD BE LIFE OR DEATH
SITUATIONS I MEAN WE SEE THIS --
ON THE HEALTH COMMISSION THAT A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO --
YOU JUST CAN'T GET TO THE THEN
BECOMES A LARGER SITUATION THE
COSTS MORE MONEY FOR THE STATE
MORE MONEY FOR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE NOW YOU GET
INTO A SITUATION WHERE THERE ARE
EMERGENCY --
ISSUES THAT COME UP SO --
IT DEFINITELY CAN I MEAN. THREE
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN DOLLARS OR
EVEN FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS EVEN A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR SOME OF MY
CLIENTS --
CAN MEAN A LOT IT CAN MEAN A LOT
IN TERMS OF GROCERIES I HAVE A
NUMBER OF CLIENTS WHO.
ARE ON CAL FRESH AND AFTER TWO
WEEKS THEY RUN OUT IN THE HAVE
TO GET TO FOOD BANKS.
AND NOT ALL RQUIRES MONEY AND
IT SEEMS LIKE SUCH A LITTLE
AMOUNT FOR A LOT OF FOLKS ARE IN
THE MIDDLE CLASS OR UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS.
BUT THIS REALLY IS IT'S JUST
CRITICAL I MEAN I I MEAN WE'RE
JUST LIKE --
REALLY ADVOCATING FOR ANY MY TV
BUT POSSIBLY A THAT WE CAN GET
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE AT THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND BELOW IN
TERMS OF THEIR INCOME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM NORTON
WORTH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'M SU WE ARE CONTEMPLATING.
AS A BODY AND AS CAL FOR
GOVERNMENT AND NUMBER AS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE YOU WOULD
ADDRESS THE SAME POPULATION IN
INCLUDING.
CONVERSATION ON THE EXPANSION OF
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
IS THERE A REASON FOR WHY IT
ADVOCATE IN SORT OF THIS
STRATEGY.
RATHER THAN SOMETHING THAT'S
TAKES MORE BROAD BASED APPROACH.
I CAN START AND THEN IF YOU IF
YOU HAVE --
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THEM MORE
NUMBER OF TOOLS WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US --
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO GO A CERTAIN PATH IF ANOTHER
PATH THAT WE WERE PLACING A LOT
OF OUR HOPES ON DIDN'T WORK.
SO I THINK THIS ALLOWS US TO
HAVE AN EXPANDED REPERTOIRE OF
UP OF PATHWAYS.
THAT'S ONE OF TO I I'M I'M
ALWAYS WONDERING THE QUESTION OF
ALSO IF THIS IS GOING TO COST
THE STATE LET'S SEE UPWARDS OF
HALF A BILLION --
BUT THEN INDIVIDUALLY SOMEWHERE
ROUGHLY AROUND THERE --
I'M SORRY. ONE ONE BILLION.
THIS IS THE WHAT ABOUT --
IF WE ARE THE SAME WAY ABOUT IT
IF IT WAS PLANTED A. B. AND
BILLION REGARDLESS OF THE AMOUNT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I THINK THE
THE THE TARGET AUDIENCE IS THE
MAXIMUM.
POSSIBLE WHICH THEN ALLOWS FOR
THERE TO BE A CONVERSATION OF
WHERE DO WE WANTED TO GO WHO WE
WANTED TO IMPACT.
THAT'LL HAVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT.
OPPORTUNITY OF THIS OFFERING
ASSISTANCE OR HELP.
LET'S NOT FORGET ALSO THIS
PROGRAM ENDED UP GETTING THE
FUNDED AT THE MOST CRITICAL TIME
AS WELL.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN WE
WERE.
A HIT WITH A CONFLUENCE OF
DIFFERENT ECONOMIC IMPACTS
INCLUDING THE HOUSING BUBBLE.
WHEN PEOPLE WERE LOSING THEIR
HOUSES --
THERE WASN'T SOME TYPE OF A
SMALL VERY SMALL RELIEF THAT
THIS OFFERS. FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
OF YOU KNOW.
APPLYING AND GETTING SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
AGAIN SMALL AMOUNT AND THE
QUESTION GOES.
TO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH ARE WE
INVESTING AND PER UNIT
CALIFORNIAN PER CAPITA WHAT IS
IT GOING TO MEAN FOR THEM --
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT I THINK WE
CAN DISCUSS.
OF MORE AS THIS BILL CONTINUES
AND WE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAYBE.
LOOK AT WHAT VERSION OF IT.
COMES OUT.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
LEAVE WITH.
SO I DON'T SEE IT AS AN EITHER
OR I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROVIDE
HELP AND ASSISTANCE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE LOW INCOME --
I WAS ONE OF THE DRAFTERS FOR S.
EIGHTY WHICH IS OUR HOUSING
FIRST BILL.
AND THE REASON BASICALLY THAT
THE GOVERNOR GAVE US THAT HE
SIGNED THAT BILL WITH BECAUSE IT
WAS A FISCAL BILL --
WHICH BASICALLY MEANS THAT ONCE
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS IT COST
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR US
TO SERVICE THAT POPULATION.
THAT MEANS TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN HELP LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS
AND LOW INCOME RENTERS YOU'RE
SAVING MONEY AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND AT THE COUNTY LEVEL --
AT THE CITY LEVEL --
WITH ALL OF THE SERVICES AND WE
SEE THIS AT THE HEALTH
COMMISSION WE HAVE OUR ANNUAL
REPORT WHICH SHOWS EXACTLY HOW
MUCH WE ARE SPENDING AND
SERVICES --
WHETHER IT'S PARAMEDICS
EMERGENCY ROOMS EMTS --
THAT THE COST IS THERE --
I NEVER WE'VE NEVER WOULD HAVE
HAD THAT BILL SIGNED HAD WE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THAT IT WAS A
FISCAL BILL AND I THINK IT'S THE
SAME THING HERE. TO ANY EXTENT
THAT YOU CAN GIVE HELP TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN HOUSING CURRENTLY --
TO STAY THERE AND TO PROVIDE
WHATEVER ASSISTANCE YOU CAN
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SAVING MONEY ON
THE OTHER END.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
I JUST I HAVE --
ONE SO I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
SO THE YOU'RE EXPANDING A
PROGRAM THAT WAS DE FUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SO WHAT IS
KIND OF THE PLAN FOR THIS BILL.
WHEN IS YOUR PLAN FOR THIS YOU
MEAN AS FOR WHERE THE FUNDING
WILL COME FROM YES?
WELL IT DEPENDS.
OR IT IS IT IS IT ARE YOU HAVE A
BUDGET REQUESTS THAT BRENT.
HELLO FROM THIS --
THERE'S GONNA BE THAT.
BUT BUT GIVEN TO WHAT EXTENT
THAT'S A POPULAR OPTION RIGHT
NOW -- I'D
LIKE FOR US TO SEE WHAT IS GOING
TO BE THE VIABLE.
OPTION MOVING FORWARD WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING.
SO IF THERE ARE OF OF IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE TAX CREDITS IF
THIS IS GONNA BE SOMETHING THAT --
MAKES SENSE RATHER THAN SOME OF
THE OTHER OPTIONS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED.
WELL THEN WE WOULD JUST NEED TO
REFORMULATE THIS TO SOME EXTENT
TO SEE WHAT WHAT MOVES FORWARD --
OTHERWISE.
THE LAST OPTION IS TO PUT IN A
REQUEST FOR FUNDING AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT OF THIS THIS IS A NO
ACTION IS A TESTIMONY ONLY ITEM
IT BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
THE ONLY THING I'D SAY IS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO DISCUSS THIS TO AT THE START
THE CONVERSATION ON IT I'M
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED THAT THIS HAD
OF THIS HAD BEEN DEFINED IT AT
THE TIME THAT IT DID.
GIVEN HOW MUCH OF A NEED THERE
WAS AT THAT TIME WHEN PEOPLE
WERE BEING DISPLACED --
AND AND FOR US TO NOT HAVE
REALLY --
DISCUSSED WAYS OF BRINGING THIS
BACK SO --
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES I
THOUGHT THAT THIS MIGHT BE.
A A GOOD OPTION OF LOOKING AT
WATER THAT SENSITIVE TARGETS.
AMONGST OUR POPULATION AMONGST
OUR DISABLED AND ELDERLY
POPULATIONS THAT WE COULD BE
LOOKING AT AND PROVIDING THIS.
INCENTIVE FOR SERVICE.
FOR SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR SHE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION AND HOPE I CAN WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU. TO TO MAKE THIS
A VIABLE YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS YOU
ARE NEXT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM HERE TO
PRESENT ON AB SIX ZERO EIGHT I
HAVE WHICH IS.
DRESSING THE LOW VALUE ORDINANCE
EXCEPTION THE PURPOSE OF THIS
SPELL IS COST EFFECTIVE PROPERTY
TAX ADMINISTRATION.
THE BILL DOES A FEW THINGS IT
WILL RATIONALIZE EXISTING LAW
GOVERNING LOW VALUE OR NEXT
ORDINANCE EXEMPTIONS.
ELIMINATE WASTEFUL AND
INEFFICIENT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
AND SAVE MONEY FOR BOTH
GOVERNMENT AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THE BILL HAS TWO PARTS.
OFFERS THE BILL ALLOWS A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO RE
EVALUATE AND AS APPROPRIATE.
INCREASED ITS LOWER VALUE
ORDINANCE EXEMPTION TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ALL
POSSESSORY INTERESTS AND SECOND
IT ALLOWS THE COUNTY ASSESSOR
THE NECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
DISCRETION IN HOW TO APPLY THE
EXEMPTION. FOR I GO ANY FURTHER
LET ME BRIEFLY EXPLAIN WHAT A
POSSESSORY INTEREST ACTUALLY IS
SO POSSESSORY INTEREST IS
PRIVATE CONTROL OF PUBLICLY
OWNED REAL PROPERTY SYSTEM
EXAMPLES INCLUDE.
A FOOD AND BEVERAGE CONCESSION
AT STADIUM IN STATE OR FEDERAL
PARKS CAR RENTAL COUNTERS AT
PUBLIC AIRPORTS VENDOR AT THE
WEEKLY FARMER'S MARKET LOCATED
ON CITY ON SPACE.
A RESTAURANT PATIO LOCATED ON A
PUBLIC SIDEWALK SO FOR EXAMPLE
OF A SMALL RESTAURANT DECIDES TO
SET UP A PATIO.
THAT OCCUPIES SPACE ON A CITY OR
COUNTY SIDEWALK I COUNTY
ASSESSOR WILL EVALUATE AND
DETERMINE THE VALUE OF THE
PUBLIC PROPERTY BEING UTILIZED
BY THE BUSINESS.
AND IF THE PROPERTY IF THE VALUE
OF THE PROPERTY IS WORTH TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE THE
BUSINESS OWNER IS THEN REQUIRED
TO PAY TAX ON THAT VALUE.
HOWEVER COUNTY ASSESSOR'S HAVE
FOUND THAT THEN WE ACTUALLY END
UP RECEIVING IN REVENUE. TO THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS LOW VALUE
THERE FOR NEEDS TO BE RE
EXAMINED AND RIGHT NOW THE LOW
VALUE ORDINANCE EXEMPTION IS SET
AT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH
SOME CATEGORIES SET AT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS BILL INCREASES THE VALUE
LIMIT TO FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR ALL POSSESSORY INTERESTS
WHICH IS A MORE REASONABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE THRESHOLD.
I AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THIS PERMITS THE PURE
PRUDENT USE OF LIMITED RESOURCES
THERE WAS A MINOR CHANGE I THINK
IT'S A WIN WIN.
FOR GOVERNMENT AND FOR SMALL
BUSINESS --
WE'VE NOTED THE COMMITTEES
FEEDBACK REGARDING THE
COMMITTEES TAX EXPENDITURE
POLICY AND AS SUCH WE WILL BE
AMENDING THE BELL.
OUTLINES SPECIFIC GOALS
OBJECTIVES AND PURPOSES AND TO
CONTAIN A FIVE YEAR SUNSET AND
AS AN ASIDE I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR.
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT
EMPHASIS ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ON I GOAL ORIENTED DECISION
MAKING.
I WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY CREEK
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
AND AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE A
SUPPORTER WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY
JESSE SALINAS IS THE YOLO COUNTY
ASSESSOR THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I GET MY NAME
IS JESSE SALINAS I AM YOUR
COUNTIES ASSESSOR CLERK RECORDER
AND REGISTER VOTERS.
AND TODAY I'M WEARING THE HAT OF
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR AND THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE SO.
WEARING NOT MULTIPLE HATS BUT
HERE TODAY AS AN ASSESSOR I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT AB SIX OH EIGHT IS
ORGANIZATIONS EFFORT TO IMPROVE
GOVERNMENT EFFECTIVENESS.
BY INCREASING THE POSSESSORY
INTEREST X. THOUSAND AS WAS JUST
SHARED --
THE APPROVAL OF THIS LEGISLATION
WILL IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF OUR ADMINISTRATION OF THESE
ASSESSMENTS.
WITH A GREAT --
PROVIDE THAT UNIFORMITY THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND AS AS A BENCHMARK AS
WELL THAT APPLIES TO EITHER A
CATEGORY SUCH IS --
THE AREAS OF OF THE AREAS OF I
APOLOGIZE THE AREAS OF LEVI'S
CONVENTION CENTERS CULTURAL
CENTERS FAIR GROUNDS AND FOR
GROUND FACILITIES.
THE OTHER ADVANTAGE IS THAT WILL
DECREASE UNDUE BURDEN.
ON AND CONFUSION TO QUALIFYING
CONSTITUENTS WHILE STILL
ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY --
LOCALLY AT THE LOCAL AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL --
TO MAKE DETERMINATIONS AS NEEDED.
SO WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH
EIGHT AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY THANK
YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME INTO QUESTION MANY DR A NO
BRAINER.
THANK YOU MISTER.
A ANA COMES QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SEEN AND YEAH.
NO LOUIS VALUE OF THE FLOORING
IT TO THE FLOOR FOR THAT.
THE SCENE THEN THIS IS THE
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THE TABLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
AS I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND I VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR ROSE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THE
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NOW I
THINK TO COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS ITEM.
I AB FOR TWENTY SEVEN WILL EXAM
MILITARY TIME AND DAY FROM STATE
INCOME TAX I INTRODUCED A
SIMILAR BILL --
IN THE LAST SESSION --
THE MAIN CONCERN FLASHERS
DISCUSSION WAS POTENTIAL LOSS OF
REVENUE TO THE GENERAL FUND. TO
REDUCE INITIAL REVOLUTE REVENUE
LOSSES STATE THIS BILL WOULD
PHASE IN THE EXEMPTION FOR EACH
RETIREE WHILE STILL KEEPING ITS
GOAL OF KEEPING RETIRED VETERANS
IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
VETERANS WHO HAVE SERVED MENTAL
TWENTY YEARS RECEIVE FEDERAL --
RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
THE GOAL THIS BILL AS WE WANT TO
KEEP OUR CAMP PENDLETON MARINES
ARE SAN DIEGO SAILORS OR FOR
WHEN SOLDIERS IN OUR EDWARDS
THURMOND STAY IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
THEY RETIRE FROM THEIR SERVICE.
BUT OUR TAX LAST YEAR VETERANS
THE OTHER STATES WERE MISSING
OUT ON THESE HIGHLY SKILLED --
EXPERIENCED WORKERS TO
COMMUNITIES WERE ONE OF ONLY ONE
OR ONLY ONE OF NINE STATES THAT
FULLY TAXES MILITARY TYRANT BAY.
AND WE'RE LOSING A LOT OF OUR
VETERANS NOT BECAUSE OF THAT --
WITH THE TODAY'S CAPTAIN DENNIS
TO BARRED FROM THE CHAIR HE IS
THE CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO
MILITARY ADVISORY COUNCIL TO
DISCUSS -- A
REPORT THEY DID IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S MILITARY
COUNCIL LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU AS THE CHAIRMAN GERMAN
BURKE AND MEMBERS TO COMMITTEES
THAT I'M DENNIS TO BART AND I'M
THE MY DAY JOB IS ON THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS TEAM A
GENTLE AN AMEX NASCO THAT'S THE
SHIPYARD IN SAN DIEGO.
BUT I'M ALSO THE TODAY HERE IS
THE CHAIR OF THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE OF SAN DIEGO MILITARY
ADVISORY COUNCIL.
AND I'M ALSO RETIRED --
NAVY VETERAN AND I LIVE IN CHULA
VISTA.
SO THOSE SAN DIEGO MILITARY
ADVISER COUNSEL IT'S NORMALLY
CALLED ESTY MAC IS A NONPROFIT
FOUNDED IN ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR IT WAS TO FACILITATE IN
ADVANCE OF COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE MILITARY LECTURED OFFICIALS
CIVIC LEADERS.
AND BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN ORDER
TO ENHANCE THE UNDERSTANDING OF
OUR MILITARY TO MANY
CONTRIBUTION THAT BRINGS OUR
REGION.
AND ESPECIALLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO I MERITED.
THE ANALYZE BOTH THE COSTS AND
THE BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA FROM
A PROPOSED EXEMPTION OF STATE
TAXES OR MILLET RETIRED MILITARY
PAY.
AND I'M ALSO TO SHARE WITH YOU
PERSPECTIVE THE BENEFITS THIS
TAX INCLUSION WOULD HAVE UPON
OUR MILITARY TYRESE.
IS THEY DECIDE TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA OR MOVE ELSEWHERE.
THE STUDY WAS DONE BY DOCTOR
LYNN REASER AT THE FOR MANY IN
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC INSTITUTE
OF POINT LOMA NAZARENE
UNIVERSITY.
YOU MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW DOCTOR
RESERVE FROM HER STUDIES AND
ALSO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURERS
COUNCIL OF ECONOMIC ADVISERS.
THE STUDY POINTED OUT IT WAS
JUST MENTION THAT ONLY NINE
STATES FULLY TAX MILITARY TYRESE
IN CALIFORNIA IS --
ONE OF THOSE STATES.
THE HIGH TAXES STATES OF NEW
YORK AND MASSACHUSETTS ARE AMONG
A MAJORITY OF STATES THAT
COMPLETELY EXEMPT MILITARY
RETIRED PAY FROM TAXES. FOR MANY
FACTORS IMPACT MILITARY TYRESE
WHERE THEY CHOOSE TO LIVE BUT
TAXES CERTAINLY ARE KEY ELEMENTS.
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE NUMBER
OF MILITARY TYRESE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCREASED BY 16%.
BUT THE SAME PER TO TIME
CALIFORNIA MILLER RETIREES
DROPPED BY ALMOST 17%.
THIS MASS MIGRATION COSTS THE
STATE REVENUE OVER THE LONG RUN.
STUDY ESTIMATED THE END OF THE
TAXATION MILITARY TIRE PAY WOULD
INCREASE NUMBER RETIREES
CHOOSING TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
BY MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND IN THE
FIRST YEAR.
AND SOON GROW TO TEN THOUSAND
MORE IN CALIFORNIA --
IN EACH YEAR AFTER THAT.
RETENTION OF TYRESE BRINGS WITH
THAT STATE REVENUES AND SALES
TAX PERSONAL INCOME TAX SOME
SECOND CAREER AND SPOUSES AND
OTHER STATE FEES AND TAXES OVER
TIME.
CERTAINLY BE A NET POSITIVE GAME
TO THE STATE REVENUE.
ALSO TAKE A MOMENT TO
PERSONALIZE THIS LEGISLATION FOR
YOUR MIND OFTEN ALMOST ST SAN
DIEGO IT'S HOME TO HUNDRED FORTY
THREE THOUSAND ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS THEIR FAMILIES.
AND APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
THOUSAND MILITARY TYRESE.
THE BILL TERRITORIES BRING
MEDICAL SKILLS TECHNOLOGY TALENT
SKILLED TRADES CERTIFICATIONS WE
ARE TEACHERS FIREMAN YOUR HIVE
TROLL OFFICERS NURSES AND MANY
OTHER.
YOU ENCOUNTER EACH AND EVERY DAY.
IN SUMMARY THIS STUDY PROVIDES A
FISCAL RATIONALE FOR EXEMPTING
MILITARY TIRED PAY FOR A MODEST
FIRST YEAR INVESTMENT ON PART.
PRODUCES LONG TERM DIVIDENDS.
ALSO SAY IT'S IN THE CLEAR
MATCHES TO OUR RETIREES AND
THANK THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE AND
THEIR VALUE TO FUTURE
CONTRIBUTIONS ESPECIALLY TO
CALIFORNIA.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
I LOOK FORWARD ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM
AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF TWENTY TWO VETERAN.
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
VIETNAM VETERANS ASSOCIATION --
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
CHAPTERS MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS.
ON SUPPORT THANK YO.
WITNESSES.
CHAIR MEMBERS MANTA CORBIN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS.
MEASURE --
IN ADDITION TO OUR OUR USUAL
CONCERNS AND I I WON'T BELABOR
THEM ALL IT'S BEEN A A LONG
HEARING --
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PRECEDENT THAT THIS SET
SPECIFICALLY CERTAINLY THE STATE
HAS A VARIETY.
OF OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO SERVE --
RESIDENCE --
FIRE POLICE AS TWO EXAMPLES --
AND THIS REALLY DOES THAT
ESTABLISH A PRECEDENT SET AS A
BIT OF A SLIPPERY SLOPE IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS THE MERIT BY WHICH
SOMEONE'S RETIREMENT PAY --
SHOULD BE EXEMPT FROM TAXATION
CERTAINLY WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
MEASURES --
THAT WOULD EXEMPT RETIREMENT PAY
FOR OTHER PARTS PROFESSIONS AS
WELL.
I AND AT A COST TO THE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS --
TO THE STATE OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS EVEN WITH THE PHASE AND WE
CONSIDER THIS TO BE PARTICULARLY
SIGNIFICANT --
AGAIN AND I'LL JUST ADD ONE LAST.
THIS WOULD GO OF COURSE TO ANY
VETERAN REGARDLESS OF THEIR NEED --
MANY VETERANS AND AND THIS WAS.
MENTIONED AND ALLUDED TO IN SOME
OF THE OPENING STATEMENTS --
ARE HIGHLY SKILLED AND COULD BE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA FRANKLY TO
MAKE A QUARTER MILLION OR A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR A YEAR SALARY --
ONLY TO ALSO HAVE THEIR
RETIREMENT PAY THAN EXEMPT FROM
TAXATION FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THERE IS OPPOSITION SAYING NINE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AS A MEMBER WITH THE
BASE AND HER DISTRICT I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
OTHER THAN THAT.
THIS IS FOR TEST MY ONLY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MEAN AND WE'VE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION ON THIS CAR
BEFORE I UNDERSTAND HER --
POINT OF VIEW BUT THE REASON
WE'RE DOING THIS IS BECAUSE IF A
YOUNG MARINE JOINS AT EIGHTEEN
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE TO RETIRE AT
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OLD AND WE
WANT THEM TO START A SECOND
CAREER HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIRTY ONE OTHER STATES
OFFER THEM INCENTIVES AND WE
WANT TO KEEP.
KEEP THOSE FOLKS IN THIS --
IN THE STATE TO BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS IN THE FUTURE AND IF
THE MARINE AT THIRTY EIGHT MOVED
TO ARIZONA THE STATE GETS ZERO
DOLLARS SO.
WE WANT THOSE VETERANS TO STAY
HERE AFTER THEIR SERVICES DONE
AND WITH THAT --
WHEN THE COMMITTEE COMES --
TO ARE SUSPEND FILE THOUGH I
WOULD ASK FOR NOTTHANK YOU IT
IS NOT A SUSPENSE MY HOPE TO BE
CLEAR.
YOU CAN SEE MY YOU CAN SEE MY
FINGER QUOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED